welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine
today my guest is Dr Jeffrey Goldberg Dr
Jeffrey Goldberg is the chair of the
Department of Ophthalmology at Stanford
University School of Medicine he is a
clinician and MD or medical doctor who
sees patients every week as well as a
PhD meaning a laboratory scientist who
directs his own laboratory focused at
understanding the mechanisms and cures
for diseases of the eye Envision such as
glaucoma retinitis Pigmentosa and
macular degeneration indeed Dr Goldberg
is one of the world leaders in
developing methods to cure blindness he
is also intensely knowledgeable about
all things related to Vision so during
today's discussion we indeed cover most
all of visual and Eye Health you will
learn for instance about the benefits as
well as drawbacks of wearing corrective
lenses such as contact lenses or
eyeglasses for reading you will learn
about the benefits and detriments of
sunlight meaning how it can help your
vision in fact how it can help reverse
or prevent my own Opia nearsightedness
as well as the things to be cautious
about with respect to sunlight in terms
of development of cataracts which are
occlusions that prevent Vision we also
discuss many tools for maintaining and
improving Vision across the lifespan
ranging from behavioral tools so
specific Vision tasks and exercises for
the eye that you can do that are known
to improve or maintain your vision as
well as specific surgical procedures
such as LASIK surgery we get into all
the details of for instance how often to
do these various eye exercises how long
the benefits are maintained as well as
age-related considerations for things
like Lasik eye surgery we even get into
how to best clean your contact lenses
whether or not to use disposable contact
lenses or other forms of contact lenses
we also discuss things like dry eye and
the best remedies for dry eye and we
talk about the scientific and clinical
data around nutritional approaches and
supplementation-based approaches for
maintaining and improving Vision so
whether or not you suffer from floaters
or dry eye or you're considering
changing your eye prescription or you
have concerns about whether or not
relying on corrective lenses is
impairing your vision and you want to
enhance your vision or if you're
somebody who has perfect vision today's
episode is going to include science and
protocols that will be highly relevant
to you I should also add that if you are
somebody who suffers from or who has
family members who suffer from diseases
of the eye that can impact Vision such
as glaucoma retinitis Pigmentosa and
macular degeneration we also delve deep
into the discussion about the most
Advanced Technologies for preventing and
offsetting vision loss due to those
diseases as well thanks to Dr Goldberg's
incredible knowledge his Clarity of
communication and his generosity with
that knowledge by the end of today's
episode You Will Be armed with all of
the modern information you need in order
to best maintain and improve your eye
and vision health before we begin I'd
like to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to Consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is Maui Nui
venison Maui Nui venison is the most
nutrient dense and delicious red meat
available I've talked before on this
podcast about the key importance of
striving to get one gram of protein per
pound of body weight now when one
strives to do that it's also important
to maximize the quality protein to
calorie ratio in other words you don't
want to consume a lot of extra calories
in order to get your quality protein
Maui Nui venison in having an extremely
high quality protein and nutrient to
calorie ratio allows you to do that very
easily and in addition to that Maui Nui
venison is delicious I particularly like
their bone broth which has an unmatched
25 grams of protein per 100 calories I
also love their ground venison and their
venison steaks all of them are
absolutely delicious if you'd like to
try Maui Nui venison go to
mauinuyvenison.com
Superman and get 20 off your first order
again that's Maui News venison.com
huberman to get 20 off today's episode
is also brought To Us by element element
is an electrolyte drink that has
everything you need that is the
electrolytes sodium magnesium and
potassium but nothing you don't which
means no sugar it's critical that we get
electrolytes because every cell of our
body but in particular our nerve cells
our neurons rely on electrolytes in
order to function properly with element
it's very easy to ingest the correct
ratios of electrolytes that come in
these little packets they're really
delicious you mix them up with anywhere
from 8 to 16 to 32 ounces of fluid I
like mine pretty concentrated so I'll
drink a 16 ounce glass of water with
element in it when I first wake up I'll
also consume another one of those maybe
32 ounces with one packet when I
exercise and maybe another one if I
happen to sweat a lot during exercise or
if I was in the sauna and sweating a lot
if it's a very hot day Etc if you'd like
to try element go to drink element
that's lmnt.com
government to claim a free element
sample pack with your purchase again
that's drink element lmnt.com huberman
today's episode is also brought To Us by
eight sleep eight sleep makes Smart
mattress covers with cooling Heating and
sleep tracking capacity now there's
absolutely no question that sleep is the
foundation of mental health physical
health and performance when we're
sleeping well and we're sleeping long
enough everything in our daily life goes
that much better now a key component to
getting a great night's sleep is the
temperature of your sleeping environment
and that's because in order to fall and
stay deeply asleep your core body
temperature actually has to drop by
about one to three degrees conversely in
order to wake up feeling refreshed your
core body temperature has to increase by
about one to three degrees with eight
Sleep mattress covers you can cool or
heat your mattress at the beginning
middle and end of your night in order to
optimize your night's sleep I started
sleeping on an eight-sleep mattress
cover about two years ago and it has
dramatically improved the sleep that I
get each and every night if you'd like
to try Aid sleep you can go to
eightsleep.com huberman and save up to
150 off their pod 3 cover eight sleep
currently ships in the USA Canada UK
select countries in the EU and Australia
again that's eightsleep.com huberman and
now for my discussion with Dr Jeffrey
Goldberg Dr Jeffrey Goldberg welcome
thanks it's great to be here you and I
go way back
we will spare people the discussion
about all of that but
I'm really excited for today's
discussion because I get a tremendous
number of questions about vision and Eye
Health and of course as a neuroscientist
who has worked on the visual system I
sometimes have answers or partial
answers but more often than not I don't
have the answers
and yet I'm confident that you do or
that if you don't you can direct us to
the proper place to get those answers so
to kick things off I want to ask you
what was one of the most commonly asked
questions when I solicited for questions
in anticipation of this episode which is
how early should one do an eye exam on
their child and how regularly should we
all be doing eye exams
also
is the fact that I think I can see
normally confirmation that I can see as
well as I think I can so that's really
three questions but baby comes out do
they check their eyes right away and if
so how and how often should they check
and what kind of information is there
yeah it's as a great question it's
obviously something that touches us all
so the the answer that really differs a
little bit uh at the different stages of
Life first of all every every baby gets
an eye exam or should be getting an eye
exam and uh one of the main things that
you really just are screening for right
when that baby is born right in the
nursery right in those first few days is
to just look for a red reflex you know
when you take a camera picture a Flash
picture and sometimes you get red eye
that's actually the light from the flash
as you know reflecting against the
retina coming back out of your eye it
looks red and
um and a red reflex is actually very
normal that's that that's great and if
you have a one of a number of
diseases in the eye that can present
even in babies even in newborn babies
including most concerning but thankfully
least common retinoblastoma which is the
most common pediatric eye cancer which
again thankfully is quite rare uh those
babies won't have a red reflex in that
eye it'll be kind of a whitish or gray
reflex and so even just that first
little you know doctor's taking the
little pen light and even just flashing
it in that's in the baby's eyes so
that's that's that's our first eye exam
and hopefully we've all had that and
hopefully every baby being born today is
getting that getting that first eye exam
is really just looking for that red
reflex
uh it's not typical as long as that's
looking good
um to worry about getting an eye exam
from there kind of through
um childhood like maybe early Elementary
School unless they your baby is
presenting with one of a number of
features that parents often pick up on
for example as the baby's aging through
those first couple of years you know
through the first couple of years babies
actually don't have great visual Acuity
and so as they're aging over those first
couple years it's normal for them to
have you know roving eye movements for
example be searching their environment
but over those first couple of years if
parents start noticing the baby isn't
you know isn't uh making eye contact or
looking where a sound is certainly if
they have what's called nystagmus like
these rapid flickering alternating eye
movements uh anything like that of
course you're going to trigger trigger
an eye exam but otherwise most babies
other than their pediatrician doing that
red reflex check when they're in for
their regular well child checks uh
that's really all that's uh needed
through that when most kids get to
elementary school age there will often
be often done at the schools and
amblyopia screening exam if kids eyes
either if one eye doesn't see that well
like maybe you're very nearsighted or
farsighted in one eye and pretty normal
sighted in the other or the two
refractive errors are quite different
from each other that can lead to a
condition you've talked about on the
podcast before called amblyopia which is
probably one of the more common or most
common eye diseases of children
or if the eyes are in a line you know
our eye muscles and the Brain behind
them are really responsible for keeping
the two eyes looking straight ahead and
if that's not working properly and one
eye is is off kilter and therefore the
image of what we're looking at is
falling on different spots of the retina
it's not sinking upright in the brain
that can lead to this disease condition
called amblyopia where that eye is no
longer talking to the brain properly and
there's a pretty easy screening exam
that can be done for strabismus the
misalignment of the eyes that kids will
do in elementary school the other main
presenting symptom of kids in elementary
school is when they admit to their
parents I can't see the board or I can't
see the teacher up front and then they
might be quite nearsighted and so that
will also trigger an exam and so those
are usually the parts for for babies for
toddlers for children school-aged
children that might reasonably trigger
an exam a couple of questions about
early eye exams and we'll um get on to
uh eye exams in older visuals in a
second but I want to interrupt you with
this question so you mentioned that um
you know there can be a misalignment of
the eyes I've seen many people's babies
where there is one eyeball that seems to
be kind of drifting around and then it
might correct but sometimes they'll have
a we don't want to get technical here
for our listeners we'll keep it General
but either convergent eyes or one eye
converging cross eyes or walleyed you
know again using uh that non-technical
language here
um and my understanding is that the
brain is taking that information in and
it's very plastic it's changing at these
early stages of development and that
it's fairly critical to get that stuff
corrected early on because if you wait
too long the brain can essentially
become blind to the the um or rather the
the brain cannot learn to handle the
proper alignment so in other words if a
kid has cross eyes
crossed eyes excuse me and they're not
corrected uh until their 20s it's
possible that they will never recover
normal vision whereas if you recover if
you align the eyes properly early in
development they can indeed recover
Vision how early can and should one
consider getting those eye realignments
done yeah yeah pretty much right on what
they'll do is if they detect any eye
misalignment and sometimes parents are
are good at noticing that and sometimes
you take a picture and one eye got the
red eye reflex and the other one didn't
and sometimes people notice that their
kids eyes are sort of turning in it
seems like too much
um sometimes there's what's called
pseudostrabismus which is where actually
depending on your Anatomy if you have a
little extra skin sort of on the inside
corners of your eyes it makes your eyes
look turned in when actually they're
straight but if your eyes are actually
turned in or slightly less common in
children more common in adults
misalignment turned out
it's really important to correct that
early and the reason is as you were
saying the brain starts ignoring it it
fails to fully develop the straw wrong
connections from the for the data coming
in from one of those two eyes into the
brain and if you pass certain sort of
thresholds during development during
childhood without correcting that
connectivity getting those two eyes to
work together properly you can
permanently lose that
um and so we use sort of we used to use
very sort of uh you know gross numbers
like it's fully correctable if you can
intervene before age three it's partly
correctable if you can intervene before
age six you got a chance before age nine
but it turns out in follow-on studies
that even kids into their young teens
have a shot at correcting that I brain
connection that amblyopia that that loss
of vision uh that that can occur during
early development so even if you're only
you know unfortunately detecting that
later on in childhood or even sort of
the tween years or early teen years it's
still worth a try to really push to
um retrain the weaker eye and then also
realign the muscles so that they can
work together to keep the eyes focused
I'll tell you it's interesting and
there's a lot more to learn about brain
plasticity and probably a lot of really
cool new
therapies yet to discover that could
reopen what's called critical period
plasticity this this this plasticity
that we have during development that
kind of goes away as we age and and that
critical period plasticity as you know
has been the best studied actually in
the visual system and the idea that we
could reopen that is really fantastic
but for different parts of that ibrain
connection there's different periods for
critical period plasticity for example
even if you get the amblyopic eye to see
well again and then you realign the eyes
and now they're working together a lot
of kids will never recover full depth
perception stereopsis the use of two
eyes to see depth for example so why
that part of the brain doesn't
correct as well as the visual Acuity or
central vision part of the brain I'm not
sure if we understand that yet
I'm going to ask for a curbside consult
as sometimes called right now by telling
you a story when I was a kid I went
swimming without goggles and I had one
eye closed and the other eye open and
closing as it went in and out of the
water because I'm a deficient swimmer
and I only breathe to one side
unless I really consciously forced
myself to breathe to both sides in a
freestyle swim got out of the pool and I
was seeing double
it was pretty eerie and then it became
downright scary because I didn't recover
my double vision until they patched one
of the eyes to forcing me to use the
other eye that had been closed the
entire time
and fortunately this was done early
enough and it I was young enough that
within I think it was about a day or so
I restored what normal vision however my
depth perception is terrible
um I'm the kid that you know Fly ball
was hit to me in the Outfield and it's
coming it's coming and then it hit me
this is why I've generally focused on
foot Sports throughout my entire life as
opposed to you know precise hand-eye
coordination I'm better at throwing
darts and things with one eye closed
than I ever would be with both eyes
maybe that's true for most people
question I have is
is it true that even just a few hours of
misalignment of information to the two
eyes early in development can
permanently rewire the brain unless
there are some corrective measures such
as patching up one eye and the example I
gave is just one but for instance if um
uh you know someone injures you know
gives a scratch on their cornea and they
close they patch the eye and the person
happens to be 10 years old is it
important to then patch the other
healthy eye after the the um you know
the scratched eye is feeling better in
other words how critical is it to ensure
the balance of information coming into
the two eyes even on the order of hours
or days yeah your story is uh it has
some features of uh you know totally
usual how we think about misaligned eyes
leading to amblyopia where one eye is
weaker patching the strong eye so the
weak eye can recover but not necessarily
fully regaining depth perception and so
that part of it is you know quite
stereotypical the part of your story
that's atypical is that for most kids
um an hour to let alone minutes an hour
to even an hour to a day if you were I
don't know if you were a young kid and
you just really were training up on
throwing darts and you were just keeping
one eye closed to throw the darts you
know really practicing for an hour a day
it'd be very unusual for that to trigger
this kind of either strabismus
misalignment of the eyes let alone
amblyopia and the strabismus is what's
giving you the double vision because
they're misaligned let alone the
amblyopia of one eye turning out weaker
if I had to guess of course not having
you know done your exam before that
fateful day in the swimming pool if I
had to guess I would guess that you may
have had some intermittent business and
your brain was already getting kind of
hit
and and you neither you nor your parents
may have even noticed it it could be
happening you know at other times a day
or you're not kind of really paying
attention it doesn't kind of stand out
in the way that that that day that you
got out of the swimming pool you really
noticed it and it may not have been that
strong it may have been quite
intermittent but if you had had some
years of intermittent isotropia or
turning in of the eyes or exotropia
turning out of the eyes that just
happened here and there but was
accumulating sort of uh damage or
failure to connect over years leading up
to that day in the swimming pool and
that day just tipped you over the edge
and you've got double vision you really
noticed it that led to an eye exam and
an eye care provider and they said wait
a second this size stronger this size
weaker you've got a little amblyopia
we're going to start patching your
strong eyes so you can get your weak eye
back so for 99.9 percent of the kids who
like you know yeah they get a little
corneal scratch or they're patching one
eye closed or or uh you know anything
that's sort of a rare event like that
nothing to worry about parents don't
have to worry kids can be kids they can
play they can do that kind of thing and
uh and not have to worry and and it's
unfortunate that we can't tell in
advance
which kid's been having the intermittent
amblyopia because we don't do a standard
eye exam on every five-year-old who's
not complaining of anything but but yeah
so that's a that's an unusual case in
yours and if I had to guess I I would
bet that you were having some sort of
subclinical untracked Uncharted
unnoticed maybe strabismus leading up to
that point okay great thank you you can
send me a bill at the end
um
along those lines
I'm 47 years old so I was part of the
generation that grew up with some
computers in the classroom but not a lot
nowadays
kids from a very young age are looking
at iPads and
phones and screens and things very close
up and there is a wealth of experimental
animal data showing that if you limit
Vision to just close range that the
eyeball lengthens and therefore the
visual image Falls in front of and not
directly onto the neural retina the
essentially the light sensing portion of
the of the eye and those animals become
myopic or nearsighted
what can we say about the environmental
conditions in which kids are seeing
from the time they're born through let's
say adolescents and their teen years in
terms of
how their visual system wires up and are
there any recommendations that are
coming from the scientific literature
clinical studies clinical trials excuse
me or otherwise that indicate what a
healthy visual environment consists of
yeah yeah that's a great question and
actually it's really relevant these days
because uh you know myopia is so common
uh it's more common
um
an Asian populations you know it's
called an epidemic in China in
California we have a lot of Asian
Heritage or Asian Americans and so we
see a lot like at Stanford we see a lot
of
um you know myopia in kids on adults and
really starting to get thoughtful on the
science of myopia control how do we how
do we provide the right environments now
what's interesting is that for decades
the Assumption some of the data really
led us to the path of thinking like gosh
the more you spend near activities and
these are Mouse model experiments like
you described but also well-designed
human cohort studies you know figuring
out like asking you know kids and
families like how long is your kid
reading or in front of the computer how
myopic are they how nearsighted are they
versus how much time is your kid in
front of the computer doing near work
how myopic or nearsighted are they and
these well-designed cohort studies did
Point tour words this concept that if
you do too much near work as a kid that
you're more likely to develop
nearsightedness as you get through those
those sort of you know uh pre-teen and
even into the teen years which is when
most of that myopia progression or
eyeball elongation is actually happening
to cause nearsightedness
it's only been in the last few years
that some really exciting Studies have
actually pointed in a slightly different
direction
and that's that maybe it's not all not
to say it's not about near activity but
maybe it's not all about near activity
maybe it's actually a little more about
the kind of light we're getting into our
eyes and I think you've talked about
this before and it's really important
when they've now studied and asked the
kids instead of just how much near and
how much far are you doing how much time
are you spending indoors in indoor
lighting which doesn't have full
spectrum light in a typical indoor
environment versus how much time are you
spending Outdoors
playing in the yard you could be reading
outside but what are you just what kind
of time are you spending outside and and
of course when you're outside in
sunlight even it's in direct sunlight
you're getting a different spectrum of
kind of Full Spectrum Lighting from the
sun and it looks like it's pretty clear
now actually that it has maybe more to
do with outdoor lighting time than just
near work and so I think that you know
we we've we've actually already seen the
first couple randomized controlled
trials where they're having kids
intentionally spending time Outdoors
versus sort of Standard Life which you
know is going to be often much more
indoor time and uh and seeing some
effects you follow those kids over a
couple of years and the kids who spend
time Outdoors are are progressing in
their nearsightedness less like they're
they're nearsighted prescription is not
getting as strong as the kid kids who
are spending more time indoors and
there's some pretty good biology that's
getting worked out going back to animal
models more about about how that might
be working in the retina in this inside
the eye but it's pretty compelling uh
concept and and so you know as a parent
uh you you may want to be you may want
to be telling your kid like okay yeah I
want you to read that book or you know
if your kids plan on the phone or
something like that or the iPad or
something like that they're allowed that
time okay you can have that time but I
want you to spend some of the time that
you're doing that Outdoors are there any
thresholds for the amount of time that
one would suggest their child be
outdoors to get that full spectrum light
it's a great question you know we talk
about cohort studies where we just ask
people what are they doing and there
seems to be you know a little bit of
what we would call a dose dependent
response maybe the more time Outdoors
might be better we don't know if there's
an upper limit like gosh if you go over
two or three hours there's no additional
benefit talk about that cohort studies
the real gold standard for answering
these kinds of questions are randomized
controlled trials and specifically
placebo-controlled or or a control group
that's not getting the intervention
that's our highest level of evidence for
clinical evidence for for any of this
kind of science when we're talking about
humans or pre-clinical models in the
laboratory and the study that hasn't
been done yet to really answer that
question is to randomize kids to telling
this group of kids you just do your
normal life tell this group of kids we
want you outside an hour this group of
kids we want you outside two hours a day
this group occurred three hours a day
and see between the groups is there a
big difference like we have pretty good
evidence now from the studies that have
been done that the difference between
zero
and one or two hours is clearly There is
five minutes enough is five hours better
I don't think we know the answers to
those questions yet like what's the
right dose but there's probably at least
some dose dependence to that and it I
can imagine it's a little bit hard to
tease apart the near far viewing from
the indoor outdoor because yes of course
a child could be outside on an iPad up
close
but it's hard to imagine that at some
point they aren't seeing off into the
distance far viewing as it's called and
the reverse is also true if you're
indoors unless you live in a very very
large home or you're staring off a
balcony far viewing is much harder to
achieve yeah so it's and perhaps it
isn't important to isolate these
variables although I can see the
challenge in developing a really good
clinical trial randomized clinical trial
for this meanwhile I I you know I'm con
I'll go into the grave shouting you know
or saying rather and suggesting that
people get some morning sunlight in
their eyes to set their circadian rhythm
um but far viewing a few at least a few
minutes and ideally hours per day or a
mixture of near and far viewing by being
outdoors just seems like a good thing to
do regardless of age so are there any
data in older people not necessarily
elderly but older people so um people in
there from say 25 years of age into
their 60s or 70s that getting outdoors
and getting this full spectrum light is
healthy for the eye in ways that are
separate from the known healthy effects
of doing that on circadian rhythm
setting yeah yeah the Circadian Parts
pretty clear the
and most patients and most in most
people the new the development of
nearsightedness happens a lot until age
10 little more through age 20. a little
more than that into the in you know in
through the 20s up to 30. tiny bit in
the 30s up to 40. but usually by those
later ages your prescription might be
changing a quarter of a diopter that's
the measurement that we use when we you
know give you your glasses prescription
a quarter of a diopter half a diopter it
could get a half after more nearsighted
or less nearsighted you know once you're
aging into your 40s 50s and Beyond so
most of the action on nearsightedness
development is actually really happening
in the younger ages so again the the
premise of intervening in an older
person and I'll just include you and me
and older people for the sake of this
definition as much as I'm reticent to do
that in general
um I think the the premise of Inc of of
sort of light modulation from
nearsightedness in older people is
probably probably not so strong I think
there are a lot of other benefits you've
talked a lot about circadian rhythm
there are so many health benefits to
exercise and you know if you're getting
Outdoors there's a good chance you're
going to be walking or bicycling you
know so so exercise value for the health
of our eyes and the rest of our body is
clearly there
um but I don't know that there's really
a strong premise that you're going to
change your glasses prescription you
know in our 40s or 50s or Beyond I'd
like to take a quick break and
acknowledge one of our sponsors athletic
greens athletic greens now called ag-1
is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that covers all of your foundational
nutritional needs I've been taking
athletic green since 2012 so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast the reason I started taking
athletic greens and the reason I still
take athletic greens once are usually
twice a day is that it gets to be the
probiotics that I need for gut health
our gut is very important it's populated
by gut microbiota that communicate with
the brain the immune system and
basically all the biological systems of
our body to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health
and those probiotics and athletic greens
are optimal and vital for microbiotic
health in addition athletic greens
contains a number of adaptogens vitamins
and minerals that make sure that all of
my foundational nutritional needs are
met and it tastes great if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticgreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 it's
probably worth touching on some of the
do's and some of the don'ts for Eye
Health generally and then I promise I'm
going to get us back to adult eye exams
because I have a lot of questions about
that
I can imagine that it's probably not a
great idea to be exposed to extremely
bright light and this is why people who
weld wear eye Shields but of course most
people are not welding
um
what other sorts of environmental
conditions are detrimental to our vision
health across the lifespan including
brightness of light we talked a little
bit about near far obviously we want to
keep toxins and acids and solvents and
things out of the eye but what do you
see
I'm not because hopefully not commonly
but what are some of the things that you
feel might not be discussed enough in
terms of Eye Health yeah you know I
think at all ages eye safety is
something that we don't talk about
enough
um you know our eyes are delicate the
front surface of the eye the cornea the
Clear Window that lets the light go into
your eye that's a delicate very
sensitive structure it's thin maybe a
millimeter at the thickest a half
millimeter in the center of our eye
uh the retina is it it's neural tissue
this is like really an outgrowth of the
brain this is very sensitive it's
subject to degenerative disease and
injury our eyes even if they just get
hit can get very inflamed our eyes can
be more inflammatory than a bruise on
our skin on our shoulder might be so eye
safety is a big one and people who are
working in certain industries
um you know anyone who's doing any metal
grinding people who are even just
gardening you know and if you're if
you're doing some significant gardening
and cutting and you could you know Fleck
a little bit of dirt you know there's a
lot of there's a lot of for example
fungus that lives in the ground natural
stuff it's all very normal in the in the
Earth but you know our eyes aren't
really made to absorb that fungus and
and have have a piece of dirt kind of
stick in our eye like that and so people
are at risk I think for you know for not
and we see too much kind of
really unnecessary eye injury eye trauma
that if people wore either their glasses
because they happen to wear prescription
glasses or goggles or for more advanced
work you know safety goggles of course
um if you're sanding doing wood shop
projects anything like that sawing
including you know again in the garden
cutting things
um you know I think I think eye safety
you know eye trauma is a big one and you
know we probably see one or two
um what we call open Globes a week come
into the Opera into the emergency room
and
um you know those are tough because you
know again the eyes delicate and it can
do a lot of healing but but not infinite
right and so we really you know that's
that's one that I think is really
an untapped opportunity is just a little
more education around
um around eye protection protecting
against eye trauma what about eye
cleanliness there's some pretty dramatic
videos also I've put some of these on my
Instagram handle of these are MRIs of
people rubbing their eyeballs and people
really getting a sense of first of all
a restatement of what you said getting a
real sense of just how much the eyes are
an outgrowth of the brain because of the
op when you see with the optic nerves
and all their beauty and the eyeballs
moving around as someone rubs their eyes
I have to imagine that rubbing your
eyeballs a little bit isn't bad but I
actually called you I don't know if you
remember when I was a junior Professor I
woke up from a nap one day and I
couldn't see out of one eye I was
freaking out so of course I called you
and I had pressure blinded Myself by
falling asleep on my hand or something
like that and you assured me that my
vision would come back and indeed it did
so you play dual role of ophthalmologist
and psychiatrist thank you and indeed I
can see out both eyes
um now
um but
rubbing our eyes getting gunk in our
eyes you know I think unless somebody
has lost their Vision temporarily
it's hard to imagine this is like a big
deal but when it happens it is truly
frightening we're so dependent on Vision
so um you know what are your
recommendations about rubbing or not
rubbing eyeballs about
um hand washing and cleanliness and also
how do you wash an eye properly yeah do
you use soap and flush it with water or
do you just flush it with water or
should you not even do that should use
saline I didn't realize these might
sound like low level questions but these
are the things that people deal with on
an all too frequent basis yeah you know
for most people most of the time
actually the eyes are a very good clean
environment and actually are tears are
are contain enzymes that help break down
bacteria and bacterial toxins and so for
most people regular eye washing doesn't
have to be any part of their standard
routine in terms of the surface of the
eye the part of your eye the conjunctiva
uh over the whites of the eyes
underneath the eyelids anything
underneath the eyelids it's pretty
self-cleaning and actually our tear
production and blinking is very good at
keeping our eyes clean the eyelids
eyelashes can be another story and
especially as we age uh we can you know
like our skin is breaking down a little
differently than when we were younger
you can develop what we sort of
nicknamed scurf which is like kind of
little dead skin bits that accumulate
around the eyelashes a lot of people
develop what we call blepharitis which
is just just means inflammation of the
eyelashes yeah and for that doing some
eye scrubs is a good idea they actually
sell little pads that you can buy kind
of little that you rip open and you can
use to kind of lightly clean the
eyelashes but you can also just use like
a No More Tears baby shampoo just pump a
little bit into the palm of your hand
once or twice a day let a little uh
dilute it with a little water and under
the sink and either with your finger or
an edge of a washcloth just very lightly
rub the eyelashes what I like to do with
the eyes closed with the eyes closed and
don't scrunch them closed too tight
because you're actually burying the
eyelashes when you do the roots of the
eyelashes when you really scrunch so
just gently close your eyes just you
know real gentle closure and then just
lightly scrub it shouldn't be abrasive
you're not trying to exfoliate the
eyelids or eyelashes in any way just
lightly rub with that kind of dilute No
More Tears baby shampoo and that can
really help people with their eye
Comfort if you feel like you've got
something in your eye your ideal eye
wash is actually going to be a sterile
Salient solution a saltwater solution
that you know they sell little bottles
over the counter eye wash Solutions like
that a lot of people wear contacts will
have that kind of eye wash solution just
a sterile saline eye wash just pure salt
water doesn't have to have any other
chemicals or preservatives in it you can
of course use not actual uh seawater or
salt water not salt water thank you yeah
not salt water out of your salt pool not
salt water out of the ocean but like a
saline salt water that's available in a
sterile now you can also just use
artificial teardrops and some of those
common non-preservatives some of those
come preserved versions those are all
also completely safe in the to use in
the eye and there you can you know you
can sort of Spritz into your eye you
know hold the lid open and give it a
little Spritz if you feel like you've
got something in your eye a piece of
dirt or A Lash that's not coming out
just to rinse it but but having like a
regular routine you know you're not
going to hurt anything with the
occasional eye rubbing we all do these
things just kind of as a you know even a
nervous habit or just absent-mindedly
you know you might you know scratch your
arm or rub your eyes or things like that
that's fine you're not going to hurt
anything there are conditions where
people sort of develop kind of a almost
like a psychological habit there are
certain conditions where people actually
do too much eye rubbing it can be
dangerous if you're in that group but
for the regular run-of-the-mill every
day occasional I rubbing fine if you
certainly if you get a lash in there and
you're trying to rub it and blink it and
tear it out and again in that situation
you can use some artificial tears
wedding drops saline drops those would
be the way to do it what an incredible
tissue the way you describe it you know
the self-cleaning and yet so delicate
a piece of the brain literally lining
the back of each of our eyes like like a
pie crust I mean it's a really
remarkable
um biological system of course I don't
have to tell you that it's just it it
never ceases to to amaze me
let's talk about eye exams in adults
so
people are aware presumably that they're
optometrists and ophthalmologists I
think it's important that we Define
their different and also overlapping
roles and
for those that you know are past High
School age probably not getting eye
exams unless they're sensing a problem
perhaps not even with blurry vision or
difficulty seeing at a distance but
sometimes just what feels like fatigue
of the eyes or a hard time maintaining
alignment of the eyes
um so how often do you recommend people
get eye exams what is a true regular eye
exam and is it important that people go
to an ophthalmologist or will an
optometrist suffice typically
optometrists are a little bit easier for
most people to access because there's
usually one someplace near an eyeglass
store so what are their roles how often
should we get our eyes checked yeah
um optometrists and ophthalmologists do
have very overlapping roles in being Eye
Care Providers there are something over
40 or 50 000 optometrists in the United
States or somewhere around 20 000
ophthalmologists in the United States
optometrists get an optometry degree
they often have OD after their name
ophthalmologists usually went you know
went to medical school so they either
have an MD after their name or they kind
of a do version of a medical degree and
uh and then optometrists will have done
additional clinical training in that
area in their area of Eye Care provision
ophthalmologist MD doctor
ophthalmologist Eye Care providers in
addition to that training will have done
surgical training in Ophthalmology
um now there's a lot of overlap and
um in both scenarios uh you can be
getting your sort of General exam taken
care of maybe a screening exam I think
that there's been a traditional
differentiation between optometrists and
ophthalmologists with optometrists
providing a little more of the primary
care eye screening maybe managing early
disease common diseases as well with
more advanced disease often sort of
upgrading to perhaps specialist
ophthalmologists in those areas but that
distinction has been declining over time
it's still true that in I think most if
not all states only the MD
ophthalmologists surgeons can do eye
surgeries but both both groups of eye
care providers can diagnose both can
prescribe appropriate eye drop
treatments including prescription eye
drop treatments for for many of our
diseases eye diseases
and um and in some states
optometrists have successfully lobbied
for uh sort of expanded rights of
providing Air Care Eye Care and again
um access to care for you know the
regular person wherever they may live is
is the most important element and so
being able to access eye care whether
it's with an optometrist in your
community or an ophthalmologist that may
be in your community or maybe at a
distance I think that's the the really
important thing is to access care now
kind of like we were talking about with
kids uh if you're in your teens 20s
maybe even 30s and not having any
problem you've got no complaints you can
see a distance you can see it near
um you know so you can read without
classes you can drive without classes
um you're not having any eye pains you
know pains around the eyes you know
redness of the eyes you may never
present to an eye care provider through
the first four Decades of life
and almost all the time it's going to be
okay right if you're not symptomatic the
chance you've got some terrible lurking
disease in there is low
but we do wish that we had a little more
screening going on because there are
some diseases glaucoma for example my
specialty the two main risk factors for
glaucoma are increasing age and that
usually presents you know in most cases
actually after age 40 but also
increasing eye pressure and if your eye
pressure is too high you can't feel that
that won't feel funny to you if it sort
of slowly is crept up over the years and
so from a screening perspective it is
good to get some kind of screening exam
could be at a public health fair could
be that you go into the local
optometrist just say hey I've never been
checked I'd like to be checked once make
sure everything's good could you ask for
sorry to interpret could somebody say
I'd like my pressures checked as I
recall the optometrist they're going to
do a puff test so they're going to blast
some air get a sense of how how rigid or
or soft again using non-clinical
non-technical language here the eyeball
happens to be
um not right now by the way I'm sure
there are are several hundreds of
thousands of people who are with eyes
closed touching the sides of their
eyeballs and I'm only half joking please
don't do this folks I'm given the
conversation we just had about eye
cleanliness and eye rubbing but my
understanding is that the old fat truly
old-fashioned eye pressure exam was you
would close your eyes and the
ophthalmologist would gently press to
see whether or not your eyes were more
rigid than last time yeah is that right
yeah that's called ballot mint and you
can kind of you can you can kind of just
take one second if you're listening and
press on your eyes just very lightly and
you there's a little give of course the
eyelids part of that give but but it's
not it's not like rock hard and if we
press and it feels under the eyelid like
gosh something under there is a rock
hard then we know something is wrong
that is way too high pressure if it's
raw card but I'll tell you our ability
to differentiate the fine points of eye
pressure other than Rock Hard or not
rock hard is pretty limited so yeah the
optometrist office or the
ophthalmologist office office as part of
a comprehensive screening exam they'll
check the eye pressure they'll look at
the surface of your eyes make sure
everything's looking healthy there
including the eyelids and lashes and
they'll look inside the eye and be able
to screen for these diseases that way
too in addition to checking if you're
complaining of any you know blurriness
at distance or at near now after age 40
or so a lot of people will present to an
eye care provider because we all get
what's called presbyopia and presbyopia
just translates to disease a vision of
the agent so you know myopia is our word
for nearsighted hyperopia is farsighted
actually amatropia means normal sighted
so I can see it distance without any
glasses I'm amitropic
but then we all get presbyopia and as we
age the lens inside our eye that's
helping focus light onto our retina gets
stiffer
such that our eye muscles are no longer
able to relax and reshape that lens and
we're not as good as we age at
moving our Focus from distance Vision
distance Vision by the way is basically
anything three feet or further away
You're basically viewing light rays
coming from Infinity once you're past
three feet so three feet or further
being able to focus that into 14 inches
or 12 inches which might be a normal
comfortable reading space for you
we lose that ability to flex our lens
relax our lens uh refocus our lens from
distance to near and most people around
age 40 could be a couple years before
could be five or ten years later that
you notice it but sort of around that
time you start needing reading glasses
you need a little extra even if you can
see fine at distance and don't need
prescription glasses for distance you
need a booster you need reading glasses
for near I don't know if you're
experiencing this yet and yeah I'm
really intrigued by this but maybe you
could clarify when you say reading
glasses do you mean just a magnifier
because I use a you know a 0.5 or a 0.75
magnifier for reading but I try and rely
on them
as little as possible and I want to get
to this about using glasses as a crutch
and the problems with that I have a
story about that too you know it's no
coincidence I decided to work on Vision
I mean after all
um I had a bunch of vision issues that
fortunately are corrected but you know I
I do experience for instance when I wake
up in the morning if I look at my phone
which by the way folks I try and get
outside and see sunlight first before
ever looking at the phone but I'll
notice when I first look at my phone in
the morning that I can see it very
clearly through my right eye but that if
I cover my right eye my left eye is
extremely blurry to the point where I'm
like oh I'm calling Jeff you know I'm
I'm afraid but then over the course of
maybe 10-15 minutes it resolves and I
don't think it's because something's in
my eye I don't think it's pressure of
having slept on that side I don't think
it's a lubrication of the eye issue
um but the two eyes seem to come into
Focus so to speak um at different rates
early in the day and if I pop my readers
on I can see right away so I will use
readers late in the day often
um if I want to read at night or
something that's right just it feels so
much more relaxing I feel like like I
can finally relax whereas otherwise I
realize that I'm straining in order to
see does is there any um clinical
clinical data and what I just described
yeah you know Andy I'll tell you my
story that's like that and
um we were living down in San Diego when
you and I were both professors at UC San
Diego
and uh we had moved into a house and I
found a pair of glasses a pair of
reading glasses uh in a closet and you
know we asked around you know did any of
the grandparents uh leave some glasses
behind nobody seemed to know who they
were so we finally just decided like
well I guess the people who moved out of
the house just left a pair of glasses
you know in this in the back of this
closet
and then I tried the glasses on
and I looked at my phone up close and
was just like oh my God wait a second I
didn't realize how blurry my near Vision
was and this is back I was about 40 42
something like that so
so I didn't even realize until I put on
the readers and these were
you know 1.25 magnifiers you know so
awesome yeah
and I'll tell you
I got addicted because who doesn't like
good Vision right right I mean oh my God
now I can make the type smaller on my
phone I can you know it was wonderful
and you can relax a bit I mean the
musculature that's responsible for for
moving the lens and focusing the eye and
then all this extraocular musculature
and we forgot I mean I'm definitely
going crow's feet
um around my eyes uh probably because I
you know squint or something but you
know just the ability to relax one's
face it just feels like you know more
more energy I feel like can be devoted
to what we're actually looking at yeah
we're not making light of this yeah well
pretty soon I just kept that one pair of
glasses with me all the time and I would
just keep them in a pocket and whip them
out whenever I was you know working at
near using my phone at a little greater
distance like a typical computer
distance I could still see the computer
fine so it really started for like kind
of that close-up phone it was it was I
could get into here but not all the way
into here
and um yeah and then pretty soon I was
just totally addicted and so you know
then I had to go buy 10 pairs and leave
them one by the bedside table you know
one in the car one in the computer bag
one on everything I work at yeah because
I'd leave them anywhere and forget them
yeah exactly you know yeah
so
um yeah so
whether using the readers
accelerates the progression of
dependence on the readers is still uh
not you know that's still up for debate
you know some studies say maybe yeah
some studies say maybe no but certainly
psychologically we get addicted to good
easy vision and if you don't have to
squint and if you're not straining your
muscles and all of a sudden the text on
your phone looks crisper again uh boy
that's addictive you're gonna like good
vision and so it feels like you're
getting dependent and how much of that
is changing the eye muscles and how much
of that is just the psychology of
wanting to have good Vision I think
probably the jury's a little bit out on
that point but point being you're either
either way your dependence will grow and
as you continue to age 40s 50s up until
about 60 65.
the ability to shape that lens gets
weaker and weaker and weaker and so you
need to move from the 0.5 to the 1.0 to
the 1.5s and to the coke bottle to the
code well thankfully not you eventually
max out at about plus 2.5 or plus three
because that's the amount of extra
refractive power that you need in
magnifiers to take the equivalent of
your Infinity viewing and bring it up to
14 inches to read it near basically you
need a plus three and then you don't
need any
lens eye muscle action whatsoever so you
kind of max out around 2.5S or threes
so because most people will hit this
somewhere in their 40s this sort of like
gosh I'm having trouble on the phone
I think most people actually use that
that's like kind of the first time for a
lot of people they're like well I guess
I should go to the eye office right see
the optometrist or maybe ophthalmologist
and when they go in they should be
getting the standard in either of those
offices will be to give you a full
screening exam including maybe it's the
puff test or a blue light test or a
little pen that can check your eye
pressure and having a look inside and
seeing if you're retina optic nerve look
healthy it's kind of screening for all
the main diseases and so and they'll
tell you at that point hey you look
great if you feel like your glasses
aren't doing it for you in a year or
three years come back or they might say
hey I've detected something I'm worried
about you and they'll set up a routine
for your ongoing Eye Care
assuming that somebody doesn't have
um you know some form of amblyopia or
the need for some a really robust
corrective lenses
and they are already using readers let's
say a plus one
or so you know plus one plus or minus
0.5 reader
would you recommend based on my
experience and based on your experience
that people strive to avoid using them
for as long as they can because in some
sense if that's the recommendation then
the recommendation is that people kind
of deal with the fact that they're
seeing a little less well or a lot less
well than they possibly could so I'm
assuming that people can still drive
well people can still read but it
involves a little bit more effort in
other words are we weakening Our Eyes by
using these these readers I I realize
you said that the data are a little bit
mixed but as long as one can perform
their required daily activities would we
be better off
delaying the use of readers
there's two important answers to that
question one is regarding the lens and
the eye muscles that control the lens
and it's entirely plausible that's what
I was saying kind of the data is mixed
on but it's plausible that if we would
just exercise like work a little harder
kind of not use as strong a reader as we
want or not use that reader as often as
we might really enjoy uh are we
exercising those muscles and kind of
exercising the ability to to stretch
versus relax the lens and kind of slow
the progression from the 1.0 reader to
the 1.25 reader to the 1.5 reader Etc
right and so that that's why I'm saying
the data is mixed but there's a good
premise that maybe if you're exercising
but let me give you the on on the other
hand it's probably ideal
to give your retina and your brain the
sharpest visual signals you can
so why hamstring your retina and your
brain and your vision and your enjoyment
and ability to read or do near work by
constantly undercutting the the reading
glasses or leaving them out or you're
not helping the whole back part of yours
maybe you're maybe you're helping the
lens but you're definitely not helping
your retina and brain by feeding it
blurry information all of that time so I
actually think just give in use the
readers have your enjoy your Best Vision
all the time and if that means wearing
glasses and by the way if that means
that you're going to have minus two
glasses for vision and you'll eventually
need minus 250s for distance Vision or
if you're going to need readers 1.5
readers now and in a few years 2.0
readers okay so you'll get the next
reader it's it's it's actually not a big
deal you can you can you know you're not
you're not hurting you're probably
helping and in the meantime it's an
enormous enjoyment to actually have good
Vision all the time right so so I
actually counsel people
just wear the glasses that work best for
you you know you're only minimally
changing how your prescription is going
to change over time very minimally so
just enjoy your Best Vision even if it's
using readers for clothes or
prescription glasses for far
I appreciate that recommendation I do
enjoy you using the readers at night it
really helps for all the reasons I
mentioned before
I've noticed that driving at night
presents an enormous strain on my visual
system and I've noticed this for a
number of years are there any I know
there's something called stationary
night blindness I don't think I'm
stationary night blind
um I think the mutation for stationary
night blindness was identified in the
Colusa horse or something like that
these were horses that you could walk up
to very easily and they wouldn't even
see you until you're right there
someone's going to correct me on this
it's the internet but I think that the
mutation was identified
um Etc but I don't think I'm stationary
night blind but I do find that driving
at night I get very fatigued and then
I'll sometimes even wear my plus one
readers when I drive at night which
removes the fatigue even though I'm
looking more or less at a distance are
there some conditions that make it hard
for people to see at night for which
they would want corrective lenses
um and what what sorts of biology
underlies that assuming that somebody is
not stationary night blind or a Colusa I
think is the name of the breed horse
yeah that's a great question you know we
for the for the optical defects in our
eyes most or many of which can be
corrected with just having the right
prescription lenses we can get away with
it without using those Corrections in
brighter light
and so during the daytime
um you know you could be slightly blurry
you know if I have a real bright light
uh and a good high contrast book you
know with black letters on the white
page I can get away with reading that
without my readers unlike if if I'm in
dim light then I feel and that might be
kind of what you're describing if you're
reading at night you actually prefer to
use the readers a little more even at
night because we can make up for a lot
of that blur if we just have bright
enough signal and contrast coming into
our eyes makes sense yeah so when you're
driving at night and noticing this this
might be revealing a little bit of a
need for glasses now I'm not suggesting
this is the answer but far more common
than having congenital stationary night
blindness would be being what's called a
latent hyper rope okay now we talked
about already how the lens inside our
eye goes from focusing it distance to
then we squeeze the muscles the lens
actually rounds up and allows us to
focus it near
some people's Optical system of their
eye is actually wired or designed or
sort of set up in length not for regular
distance which would be anywhere from
about three feet to Infinity
but it's actually designed it's actually
tuned for being beyond Infinity which
doesn't make any actual sense when you
talk about it but just the Optics of the
eye at their best Focus are actually
focusing the light behind the retina and
and if you're doing that when you're
younger you're actually using some of
your focusing power to to use those
muscles strain those muscles relax that
lens round up that lens and have your
vision Focus From Beyond Infinity to
normal distance like distance vision and
so if you're a latent hyperope you are
constantly using those muscles and again
if you're tired it's the end of the day
your muscles are feeling a little
fatigued uh your latent hyperopia or by
the way if you've had a drink or two
alcohol can do this too your latent
hyperopia can kind of kick in especially
as we're age and we're not as good at
refocusing that lens anyway and now all
of a sudden your vision is kind of
reverting to its natural state which is
slightly out of focus at distance
because it's actually focused beyond
Infinity if you will and so all of a
sudden you put on that plus one just for
a little extra booster kick and you're
like oh yeah yeah distance vision is
clean and easy now so
I'll have to bring you into the clinic
to really be sure but you could be
exhibiting a little bit of that kind of
latent hyperopia I definitely want the
eye exam and I want it from you and I've
been called a lot of things in life um
and we can now let add perhaps latent
hyper
opiate
uh to that
I'd like to take a quick break and thank
our sponsor inside tracker inside
tracker is a personalized nutrition
platform that analyzes data from your
blood and DNA to help you better
understand your body and help you reach
your health goals I've long been a
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
assessed with a quality blood test the
problem with a lot of blood and DNA
tests out there however is that they'll
give you information about certain lipid
markers or hormone markers but no
information about what to do with all of
that data inside tracker makes it very
easy to look at your levels of hormones
metabolic factors lipids Etc and then to
assess what sorts of Behavioral
nutritional supplementation or perhaps
other interventions you might want to
use to bring those numbers into the
ranges that are appropriate and indeed
optimal for you if you'd like to try
inside tracker you can visit
insidetracker.com huberman and get 20
off any of inside tracker's plans that's
inside tracker.com huberman to get 20
off another easier and again this
discussion is not designed to be an eye
exam for me but I have yet another
experience that I think illustrates the
key importance of both critical period
plasticity and the questions about
whether or not to rely on corrective
lenses and that is from the time I was
pretty young I could make my sister
laugh by deviating one eye inward so not
crossing my eyes but moving one eye
Inward and then what happened was when I
was in college and studying a lot a lot
and getting very fatigued I noticed that
this I started just kind of drifting a
little bit so I went to the campus
Health Center and they gave me a
prescription for a prism lens which of
course redirects the image but then I
noticed that this eyeball moving Inward
and I guess for those of you watching on
uh on YouTube and not just listening um
I can do this
um by just moving one eye in all right
as I can move this side yeah it's a
fairly pronounced it started to really
drift in at a relaxation State and I
started seeing double again so I thought
whoa these prism this one prism lens is
a crutch of the sort that I really don't
want crushed the glasses it broke them
and it never went back to them
um I have voluntary control over it but
that's one example where the corrective
lens can actually create a pretty
significant shift in eye position if one
relies on it so this gets back to this
issue of
um when should people Force themselves
to work with their natural vision maybe
do some more far viewing
um as opposed and certainly get outside
and get sunlight into the sunlight full
spectrum light as opposed to relying on
active lenses yeah and and you've raised
a very important distinction here and
that's the distinction between the
muscles that are inside our eye that we
use to relax and refocus the lens and
the muscles that are on the outside of
the eyeball of course inside our orbit
but on the outside of the eyeball that
turn the eyes and if everything's
working right keeps our eyes really
yoked straight and we talked about
earlier uh this possibility that you may
have been having a little bit of
intermittent esotropia or intermittent
turning in of the eyes that then
culminated on that day of a day at the
pool when you really noticed it
and your ongoing ability to actually
turn one eye in could be related to that
I remember as a kid standing in front of
the mirror and I I couldn't get my eyes
to cross even though friends could do it
and you know so you know I I was in the
losing group on that on that end you
became an ophthalmologist and then I
became an ophthalmologist and I must say
it is very reassuring that you have
excellent Vision you know I always worry
when I go to a new dentist and then I
look up at them in one moment and if
they're not wearing a mask that their
teeth are not you know pristine I think
well what am I doing here so at you know
an ophthalmologist with excellent Vision
brings me uh great comfort the toddler's
children should have shoes right exactly
um but yeah so so when to correct when
not to correct with lenses and I realize
here we haven't talked at all about
contacts we've been talking about
eyeglasses yeah let's come to contacts
in a sec if you want but yeah let me
return to your question the difference
between providing corrective lenses that
allow you to focus for near or distance
uh in your glasses so that you can go
easy on the inside the eye eye muscle
having to work so hard a lot of people
get eye strain and sort of uh headaches
even from that from not having adequate
correction that they're wearing that's
different actually especially when we're
children or again into that maybe even
into the teens and even young adult
years
from the eye muscles on the outside of
the eyes which are supposed to be yoking
our eyes straight and so that you have
them both looking at the same point in
space and and there it's actually quite
a common treatment to try to under
correct and ask people to exercise and
not just give a prism that says hey if
your eyes in sometime we'll use a prism
so the light sort of looks right to you
but rather under correct that and sort
of really force you to exercise trying
to yoke your two eyes straight together
and so that's that's in contrast and
they're actually I think many
optometrists who often specialize in in
what are the right glasses to give in a
situation like that wherever possible
especially during
uh development as our bodies are
developing as we're sort of growing in
our younger years uh take the approach
of intentionally trying to under correct
not use a prism or not use a full prism
correction uh and um to really help uh
sometimes it's also like an
accommodative reflex that your eyes are
just you're spending so much time
reading it near when you read it near
your eyes actually naturally turn in a
little bit to focus uh at that nearer so
that they can be looking at the same
word on the page and that can also if
you've got kind of too much muscle drive
you can overshoot that and so sometimes
just using not a prism but like a little
bit of a plus lens in kids just so they
don't have to work quite so hard to turn
their eyes in and sort of over exercise
those muscles these are all great
examples we're going to an eye care
provider often for these kinds of issues
an optometrist is the right first place
to start
you'd like to say that every optometrist
and every ophthalmologist is always
going to give the exact right thing for
for each kid or young adult or older
adult to do and and we wish all medical
care providers were were always right on
Target and a lot of times it's a perfect
science but a lot of times it's an
imperfect science and so it could be
that at least with you know we're now 20
25 30 years later but like it could be
that today that 20 year old version of
yourself would have been given a
different uh approach to having one eye
intermittently occasionally turning in
like that is there any real value to
um near far exercises you know so-called
pencil push-ups or a smooth Pursuit
tracking I've talked a little bit about
it before on the podcast but that was
you know some time ago so what are your
thoughts on on that is there any value
whatsoever I mean they require a little
bit of work just like going to the gym
but you know you know 25 reps a day of
near far
um especially as one is transitioning
from age 30 to age 50
um is it worthwhile yeah is it harmful
in any way definitely not harmful and
again uh you know would it slow down or
sort of uh slow down your progression to
presbyopia or needing those reading
glasses uh could be some people also
develop
um sort of uh you know a real failure to
properly turn their eyes in and so they
actually would benefit if you've been
diagnosed with that inability or having
double vision at near but not at
distance
um so that kind of convergence in
insufficiency for example then then
pencil push-ups off and get prescribed
as a way to try to exercise those skills
and you know uh in your eye muscles I
should interrupt here and just tell
people for those of you that are
listening not watching the pencil
push-up we can put a link to it in the
show note caption so it's essentially
taking a pen or pencil looking at it at
um at arm's distance and then slowly
moving it toward your nose and
deliberately working hard and it is a
bit of effort to continue to focus on it
at a close distance at some point it
will become blurry because I can't cross
my eyes any further unless I become a
cyclops and then moving it back out
again and doing that for you know 10 to
25 repetitions maybe once or twice a day
a few times a week that's what those are
pencil push-ups yeah yeah so
um you're certainly not going to hurt
anything there are other situations
where those really do get prescribed and
there's definitely some good clinical
trial data suggesting that they can
actually help for example recovery from
concussion a lot of people actually
one of the really telling ways to
diagnose concussion and this can be
concussion from sports or a fall or you
know any any source of concussion your
smooth Pursuit which is the ability
let's say I've got a DOT moving around
in a circle on a screen and I'm
following that thought with my eyes my
eyes should be able to very smoothly
follow that circle around
watching a hockey game is that like your
body fan right like that you know just
following a ball you know following any
movement with smooth Pursuits of your
eyes
and after concussion that actually those
systems in our brain the sort of
reflexive ability to properly follow
that use that visual input to tell your
eye muscles exactly where to move
gets disrupted and so all of a sudden
your smooth Pursuit starts to look
choppy it's not so smooth anymore and
it's actually a way to diagnose and
follow recovery from concussion and part
of the visual rehab sort of neuro rehab
one of the approaches being used and
further studied still in recovery from
concussion is actually doing those kinds
of exercises like pencil push-ups or
basically what you've described is
focusing from far away to focusing near
and doing that back and forth and using
that to sort of like help regain uh the
tighter control of our eye movements and
that eye brain connection so if
traumatic brain injury causes deficits
in smooth Pursuit eye movements and some
of the recovery protocols for traumatic
brain injury are to have people do
smooth Pursuit protocols and pencil
push-ups are these also the sorts of
things that anyone can just do I mean
whenever possible we like to share tools
for various aspects of Health on this
podcast but of course we don't want
people cowboying this stuff in a way
that could be detrimental to their to
their Vision so is it okay to get on
YouTube and find a smooth Pursuit um
Tool uh we can put a link to these there
there are several of them
um and people spend a few minutes doing
this yeah
you're definitely not going to hurt
anything so totally fine to do it and
some people may notice you know like
they feel a little more visually active
if they do these kinds of exercises
um I think most people would do them and
not notice something in their daily life
we actually have
um
made so much progress you know in
research in thinking about how do we
take the diseased or dysfunctioning or
aging eye and get it back to healthy and
normal
but there's a whole other area of
science that's we're really just barely
touching we've actually we've actually
just opened a vision performance center
to really get at not just how do we
rehab the sick eye back to health but
what's the difference between
functioning normally and functioning
above normally
for example athletes when they get
studied for visual Vision
characteristics they have faster visual
reflexes higher visual Acuity uh how
much of that was you know genetic how
much of that is trained we don't really
understand could we train all of us with
you know normal vision to get up to
Supra normal vision these are like great
important questions that are really
relevant to you know every regular
person of course you know people doing
Esports and the gaming communities and
athletes is part of what we're studying
in the vision performance center but
these are really really big
opportunities to try to understand how
do we move people from normal vision to
Super normal vision and there's evidence
that you can do it so here's a great
example some athletes train
using these special goggles that
actually use electrical signals in the
glasses part of the goggles to actually
black out your vision one thirtieth of
every second two thirtieths of every
second three thirtieths of every second
now imagine you and I are passing a
basketball back and forth except you're
wearing goggles and all of a sudden
you're only getting 90 percent of the
data of where's that basketball on its
way to my hands now you're only getting
eighty percent now you're only getting
70 percent of that visual information
and you are practicing right you are
getting good at catching a basketball
when you only have a fraction of the
visual information and now I put you
back on the basketball court without the
goggles you might be really good at
passing that basketball around and
catching that basketball right and so
the idea that we could train and
understand the biology of training to
get the eyes from normal to supernormal
Performance I think it's an amazing area
and one that we've really just started
to dig into that's fantastic so this is
a a new program at Stanford through the
department of Ophthalmology is it linked
up at all with the woosai performance
Institute yeah actually there's been a
lot of focus over the years I think in
human performance and there's actually a
new human performance uh Alliance and
Center we've we've we've long had really
run through the department of our
Orthopedics a human performance
laboratory that's really you know much
more about joints and muscles and
strength and conditioning and stretching
to layer on to that now a real
understanding of how vision is operating
you know it's interesting let's go back
to the example of concussion you know
we've got I don't know about 800 Varsity
student athletes and all the different
sports at Stanford and you might have a
student athlete come in and say you know
something doesn't feel right I got a
little hit on the head I feel like my
vision is a little bit messed up maybe
I've got a mild concussion you could
imagine doing some of these tests on
some of these performance athletes for
example and saying well gosh you look
normal
but actually they used to be operating
at a supernormal rate and this is a
noticeable decrement for them and so
just starting to study and understand
what's the difference between normal and
supernormal how do we go back and forth
between those two how do we measure that
difference and maybe ultimately how do
we train into that difference I think
it's going to be exciting and not just
for athletes you know for for regular
people you know you talk about driving
at night is there a solution where we
could train our eyes to be better at
driving at night and I don't know maybe
reduce the number of accidents that
happen out in the world so well
certainly there's
um physical training protocols which are
redefining what a 60 year old or 70 year
old
could look like and feel like and be
able to perform like why not do the same
for vision
um so I don't think there's anything
Supernatural or greedy about doing it I
think that's the excitement of biology
and neuroplasticity that you can extend
it forward as opposed to just trying to
wire up correctly during development
this is a perfect time for me to ask you
a question that I'd love a clear answer
on if it's possible it's not always
possible which is
could you define 2020 vision and a few
of the variants so that any person could
understand it so we think of 2020 as
perfect vision what does that mean what
would degraded Vision look like
whatever those numbers are and then what
would above normal super normal vision
look like yeah and is it true that
fighter pilots have Supra normal vision
yeah that's another population like like
like many athletes of of people who may
have sort of better than normal vision
2020 you know we Define almost
everything we do based on you know kind
of a average not sick human being adult
whatever it is right and so 2020 Vision
means that you can read the smallest
letters at 20 feet away that the average
healthy person can read
at 20 feet away so you can read at 20
what they can read at 20. okay now if
you have worse than 20 20 Vision maybe
you have 20 25 Vision 2040 Vision maybe
you have 2200 Vision which on the eye
chart at the office is like the Big E at
the very top is 2200 Vision that means
you can read at 20 feet what a normal
person could read at 200 feet right so
you've got pretty limited lower Vision
we can measure down to like 2400 2800 at
that point we're getting into like gosh
can you count how many fingers I'm
holding up you know that kind of thing
and then ultimately hand motion can you
even tell if my hand is moving in this
side of your vision or this side of your
vision
and then ultimately after that light
perception can you tell if the room
lights are on or off right and that's
kind of the edge of of being actually
fully blind we call Legal blindness in
the United States typically 2200 or
worse and is it true that there are
people who are legally blind that are
out there driving as we're having this
conversation I I have to imagine that
that is unfortunately the case but it
shouldn't be because those people
obviously are really severely impaired
and and that's obviously quite dangerous
so so so that's 20 20. now
it gets worse 2040 2080 20 100 can it
get better yeah it turns out that people
can be sort of on the other end of that
curve and so we could have athletes and
fighter pilots or people who have had
LASIK surgery who are 2015
2010. if you're 2010 that means you can
see it 20 feet what the average person
needs to be only 10 feet away to see
right and so you've got better than
normal vision and people do get to that
through a variety of ways and so it is
possible to have better than 20 20
vision
does the degree of visual Acuity because
that's really what we're talking about
here differ dramatically between the two
eyes
in most healthy people know
um you know remember we talked about
you're born with something like 2200
Vision takes you a couple of years and
it can be a little bit asymmetric 2200
Vision yeah that reminds me um I've seen
images of what babies can see you know
parents love looking at their child and
thinking their child is looking right
back at them and indeed often the child
is looking right back at them and your
face to your child sorry to break this
to you folks is incredibly blurry even
at that close distance for probably the
first six to eight months events before
you come into sharp relief they're not
seeing the fine details of your face
yeah so smile big that's right smile
break keep those eyebrows dark right and
keep cooing at them because they can
hear pretty well that's right yeah the
Optics of newborn babies are just
dreadfully bad yeah but they need
visuals now other species not you know
Hawks
Raptors owls that hunt uh they can
naturally have 2010 28 Vision right so
much better vision and that's just their
normal vision as best as has been
measured so so there's definitely the
potential for us to have better than 20
20 Vision now all of this we call Visual
Acuity and just to be clear for everyone
that's the vision in the very center of
your vision like when you're reading or
looking that's the very center of your
vision
our vision is actually described
variably as a hill of vision the peak is
in the center that's let's say 2020 in
most people right but it's it's normal
to have that slope off and our visual
Acuity your ability to read the eye
chart on the edges of your vision if you
can read the Big E that's pretty normal
like you would be 2200 out on the edges
of your vision and we would feel like
yep that's pretty normal
um so so our highest Acuity Visions in
the center and that's a big part of why
we spend a lot of time using those eye
muscles to look around right we gotta we
gotta get a little bit of a high Acuity
view of what's around us uh fill in fill
in the gaps of what our what our brain
is is interpreting our peripheral world
to look like it's almost like we have
two visual systems we have a high Acuity
High pixel density camera in the middle
and then surrounding that is a pretty
low resolution but very fast detector
camera yes yeah yeah you mentioned Lasik
but I want to make sure that before we
talk about Lasik that we talk a little
bit about contact lenses is there any
detriment to having a piece of glass or
a piece of plastic on the front of your
eye all the time and the reason I ask is
not because I think we should live
necessarily exactly like our ancestors
but it's a pretty bizarre adaptation
to put a lens directly onto the front of
the eye you have to imagine that the
cells and tissues there are accustomed
to getting a certain amount of oxygen
they're accustomed to get a certain
amount of interaction with the
environment and and you also are now
adding another surface the way that the
tears are going to interact with the
um you know with the cornea of the eye
are probably changed and who knows maybe
it doesn't make any negative difference
at all but you know putting a contact
lens on the front of the eye is you know
about as close to putting a device on
your brain as I can think of except for
maybe the cochlear uh implant yeah yeah
that's a great question now first of all
um I want to distinguish uh there are a
few really medical uses for different
kinds of contact lenses like scleral
contact lenses for people of certain
diseases there are other kinds but I
think what we really want to talk about
right now is just kind of the
run-of-the-mill I want to get my
prescription taken care of but instead
of wearing glasses I'm going to wear
contacts
contacts even the newest generation
contacts yes they sort of uh change the
tier Dynamics on the surface of your eye
they
um they decrease the oxygen you know
diffusion that's just sort of out in the
air onto the surface of our eye onto the
cells that are on the surface of our eye
but most of us especially as we're
younger have enough tear film Reserve
enough oxygen Reserve that we can easily
tolerate these polymer gel soft contact
lenses and and wear them happily the
advantage of contact lenses over glasses
purely from the perspective of
correcting your vision is that there's
different elements of of of of of the
shape of your eye that need to be
corrected if you need corrective lenses
and so for example if you're for the
basketball shape of your eye is a little
too steep or a little too shallow that's
what the standard glasses correct you
may have been told that you have
something called astigmatism that's
where instead of having a basketball
shaped eye you have a slightly football
shaped die it's not round in the same
dimensions on both axes and again
glasses can correct that but then
there's higher order aberrations in our
corneas in the clear window in the front
of our eyes or or to some degree in the
lens inside the eye that are that are
focusing the light that the glasses
prescription can't correct but if you
have a nice smooth contact lens on the
front it can correct so a lot of people
who wear glasses and contacts will
report that they have a much higher
quality of vision with their contact
lens correction than with their glasses
correction and again in service of
enjoying the best Vision that you can
enjoy in your daily life that's an
upside to seeing if contacts could work
Frio now there's another element though
and that's like gosh is there a risk of
contact lenses and especially as we age
um we have less tear film reserves so
contacts may become less tolerable as we
age
and the other thing is being really good
about the cleaning because you know the
contacts can trap bacteria or fungus and
if you get a corneal infection from a
contact lens it actually can be quite
devastating to your cornea even if you
successfully treat the infection you can
be left with some corneal scarring
thankfully this happens very rarely but
when it does happen it can be quite
difficult on you know on the person
thereafter to sort of suffer through
having maybe a scar from that infection
on the surface of their cornea that they
that leads to some blurring vision for
example so we always recommend that if
you're going to wear contacts that you'd
be really attentive to whether you're
tolerating them well
and then also to be really attentive to
the recommended use and cleaning of the
contact lenses I actually recommend that
even though they're a little more
expensive to afford that people should
almost always be just using the daily
contact lenses that they don't have to
clean or use for you know two weeks or
four week period so these are disposable
contacts highly disposable and I hate to
think of you know I don't know filling
our oceans or what have you with uh more
more more polymer plastic but at least
the contact lenses are small and it's
much safer for your eye to use a daily
disposable than to use a two week or a
four week and be responsible for the
cleaning the other thing to be really
responsible about is sleeping in them
overnight because overnight when your
eyelids are closed of course now you're
getting even less oxygen to the surface
of your eye actually most bacteria
especially many of the Infectious
bacteria to our bodies and to the
surface of our eye are actually bacteria
that Don don't really like oxygen and so
we've got a low risk of getting
bacterial infections on the surface of
our eye but if we use contacts too much
don't clean them or sleep in them
overnight when our eyelids are closed
and now there's even less oxygen kind of
helping keep the surface more more clean
if you will that increases the risk a
lot so being really good with the
recommended use and cleaning of the
contacts is critical considering daily
use contacts you don't have to and look
most contacts are going to be the two
week or four-week kind where you put
them in the cleaning solution overnight
each time give them a good rinse and put
them back in the next day and again most
people 99.99 some percent of people are
going to do just fine with that follow
the instructions and never get into
trouble
as we age they're going to become less
tolerable people are going to say I used
to wear my contacts for 12 hours now my
eyes feel really dry after six or eight
or ten hours
maybe some years after that they say
gosh I could barely use it for four
hours I only use them when I go out on a
Saturday night uh and and that's okay
you can you can you can back off as you
need to back off but in the meantime if
it helps you especially in the younger
decades if it helps you really enjoy uh
Your Best Vision great
what about UV protection in eyeglass
lenses and or contacts
I've dealt with many questions about
blue light I am not somebody who
believes that all blue light is terrible
I think it's important to avoid Bright
Lights of any wavelength late at night
if you want your melatonin production to
be normal and you want to sleep well it
doesn't matter if you're wearing blue
blockers or not if you're just under
blastingly Bright Lights it's going to
suppress your melatonin and yet some
people enjoy blue blockers for that
reason nowadays A lot of people wear
blue blocker
glasses or blue blocking lenses or
contacts throughout the entire day
thinking that blue light is bad for our
eyes during the day I happen to
subscribe to the idea that we want as
much bright light as we safely can
tolerate during the day ideally from
sunlight
in order to set our circadian rhythm and
yet a lot of eyeglasses and a lot of
contact lenses out there have UV a and
or UVB blocking features to them so what
are your thoughts on this and I'm
perfectly happy to be wrong and revise
my my stance on this
um yeah what what do you think about
this UV a B blocking yeah it's a good
it's it's a it's really important to
distinguish that UV light on the light
spectrum is right next to blue light red
lights on the other end and of course
infrared is beyond that and our eyes
other animals can see these but our eyes
can't see infrared that's why we call it
Beyond red and we can't see ultraviolet
we call it Beyond violet UV light is
right next to Blue Light UV light is
known to have a lot of adverse effects
it's not really good for our skin and
therefore you know we really want to
avoid Sunburn and kind of UV data you
know exposure and damage on our skin
similarly it's not really good on our
eyes and it affects both the ocular
surface a little bit in terms of like
kind of how dry or irritable your eyes
might feel for some people and certainly
over the long term UV light will
accelerate the formation of cataract
which is a blurring of an oxidative
blurring of the lens inside the eye
profound UV light can be damaging to the
retina if you're getting way too much on
the inside
so uh so blocking UV light I believe is
just absolutely standard in every pair
of eyeglasses and I don't know actually
how much to what degree the different
kinds of contact lenses also filter at
least UV light now blue blockers blue
blocking glasses is totally different
and
as I say like I think almost all glasses
because the Plastics almost all glasses
are not made of glass anymore they're
made of plastics but I think almost all
of them now filter the UV light which
again is like probably the safe move for
our eyes and periocular environment
around the eye environment
so blue blockers you know that's been a
huge fan I'll tell you the last three
years through the pandemic everybody
getting on their computer hours in front
of Zoom meetings where we used to walk
from building to building for a meeting
things like that
um I you know I I remember you know like
this sort of big uptick in these kinds
of questions and I'm not sure that
there's any data that blocking blue is
helpful in any way and as you say it may
actually play into sort of circadian
entrainment of our natural daily Rhythm
so so I think blocking UV is a good idea
and I think it's pretty standard you
know they make glasses is by the way
that actually react to UV light they're
called transitions there may be a few
different brands I don't know uh but but
you know these are the sunglasses that
are clear except then they turn dark if
you're out in the sunlight and it's not
just any sunlight it's actually the UV
wavelengths that that cause the chemical
reaction in the glasses to turn from
from Clear see-through to to sunglass
blocked glasses
and um
you may notice if you if any of you out
there are using these kinds of glasses
uh that they don't work in the car
you'll wear them in the car and they
won't go to sunglasses even though it's
sunny out and again that's because all
standard car glass also filters UV
that's why if you're riding around in
the car and it's sunny out you've got
your hand you know up next to the window
uh wearing a t-shirt you never get a
sunburn through the car window anymore
because all our car glasses also
filtering UV light for us so so that's a
very informative answer and before we
started recording you and I were
discussing this practice of morning
sunlight viewing which again I highly
recommend over and over and you pointed
out that low solar angle sunlight so
sunlight low in the sky viewed for maybe
10 minutes a morning and again not
forcing oneself to look at it and stare
but blinking as needed is not going to
cause extensive UV damage to the eyes
it's really the when the sun is directly
overhead that we're getting a lot of UV
which raises this other question which
is for people that don't wear corrective
lenses and therefore are not blocking UV
light to the eyes
um what should they do are they in
trouble should they be wearing a brimmed
hat brimmed Hat's a great idea that I've
got a rid of a lot of the direct light
into the eye of course you still have
reflected light off of surfaces and that
that can include UV light of course
um you know wearing sunglasses outside
even if you don't have corrective lenses
you know it's may also be more
comfortable to wear sunglasses outside
um so so these are all fine you know
at the end of the day it's probably not
making a huge difference in the health
of your eye whether you've spent the
last 50 years wearing sunglasses really
dogmatically for your outdoor time or
not you know if you were going to
develop let's just say age-related
cataracts inside your eyes which
we'll all get if we all live to 120 we
all get cataracts you know it's going to
happen some people younger some people
older maybe if you were really dogmatic
about wearing your UV blocking
sunglasses maybe you'd get your your
cataracts at 75 years old instead of 72
years old it may not be a huge
difference in that regard so again not
something to be super stressed I think
it's I think it's more a question of
just what are you comfortable in uh and
then certainly I will say the the other
advantage of a wide brim hat is it's
keeping sun off of your face and these
are the you know some of the especially
the upturned portions of your face like
the cheeks and the nose these are the
some of the most common places to get
some of the skin cancers that you can
get over a lifetime of sunlight exposure
so you know the wide brain app is it's
helping you for that as well
can't help but ask about comfort
at varying levels of brightness I'm the
person that when sitting in a cafe or
something and on a bright day I can be
directly across from somebody like you
who seems to be perfectly fine without
sunglasses and maybe even more shaded
under an umbrella or something of that
sort and I'm squinting like crazy
is it normal for there to be a pretty
wide variation in sensitivity to light
and does this have anything to do with
the lightness or darkness of the eyes
you have brown eyes I have green eyes
but is there any real correlation there
yeah you know it's a good question I
don't know if it's been formally studied
but I will tell you like I have the same
impression you do which is that if you
have uh blue eyes or light-colored eyes
that you're more likely to have more
sensitivity we know that there's
differences in the iris muscles that
constrict and dilate in response to
light
for example when you go into your eye
care provider and they're going to do a
dilated exam and they put the eye drops
in your eye that dilate the eyes they
sort of change the the nerve impulses
onto the iris muscles of the iris
dilates and you get those big big open
eyes
um people with blue eyes we absolutely
know blue or Hazel or light colored eyes
uh you put that eye drop to dilate there
rise it's going to last four six eight
hours whereas in a brown-eyed person
often the dilation only lasts one two
four hours so there's clearly biological
differences between the irises and their
muscles and maybe the nerves that feed
those muscles uh between light-eyed
people and and darker eyed people and
that may also therefore relate to this
differential sensitivity that some
people have you know if you're not able
to constrict your eyes in the bright
light as effectively you're going to
find that bright light more frustrating
more annoying uh you know even painful
people will feel like their eyes are
cramping almost as they try to get that
those eye muscles to activate to bring
down the pupil and block some of that
excess light from getting in interesting
yeah let's go back to Lasik what is
LASIK and
should I get Lasik eye surgery does it
does everyone need Lasik can it help
every can it make us you know
suprophysiological you know can it make
me a 2010. you know often it can I'll
just say that you know right up front it
is amazing people will come out of Lasik
surgery uh better than 2020 but uh the
cornea we talked about before that's the
Clear Window on the front of your eye
all the light has to get through there
and we talked about before already like
if your cornea is misshapen if the
basketball shape of it is too too
shallow or too steep then you're going
to need glasses to see a distance and
also at near if it's to football instead
of basketball then it's going to be what
we call astigmatism and uh and then you
can't you need a correction for that
instead of correcting with glasses that
sort of help shape the light so it can
go through your slightly off-shaped
cornea instead of wearing contact lenses
which also shape the light just as it's
entering your cornea right on the
surface of the eye you can just reshape
the cornea
and the way Lasik does that there's a
few different versions of Lasik but
basically the way the Lasik does that is
it actually ablates or uh gets rid of a
little ring or rim of that corneal
tissue
so that for example if you were a little
shallow and you got rid of a little bit
of that tissue around the edge with the
laser the Lasik you know starts with the
word laser if you got rid of that edge
tissue then you're sort of making it a
little more basketball shaped right or
if you were too steep on your cornea and
you used the laser to kind of shave off
a little bit of the the tip of that
basketball right then you're flattening
it out flattening out the cornea so it's
that kind of reshaping and the
technology has come so far that the
Lasik procedures can actually correct
not just the regular aberrations that we
talked about but also some of these
higher order aberrations and there are
different monikers for this kind of
Lasik it's all I think become fairly
standard but wave front guided where
it's actually using light waves to
measure with a very exact localization
exactly how much and where to laser for
each individual eye to make that cornea
pass the light as ideally as possible
now one or a few percent of patients
will actually have a dry eye problem so
after a Lasik because so it does
interfere a little bit with those
corneal nerves for example and I and I
do think that if you're a person who
already has dry eye hopefully if you're
asking your eye surgeon about Lasik
hopefully you're being counseled that if
you have dry eye this might not be a
good idea for you just like contacts
might not be a good idea for you if you
already have a lot of dry eye but for a
lot of people especially a lot of
younger people it's quite common I I
think the statistics suggests maybe 15
or 20 percent of people who would
benefit from LASIK you know who who
would who would otherwise be wearing
glasses may get Lasik at some point in
their life and
um you know I used to joke
you know Lasik it costs more money than
a pair of glasses but
it doesn't cost more money than 10 pairs
of prescription glasses over the course
of a decade or two you know and so I
used to joke that gosh if uh if everyone
had to have laser eye surgery for their
best vision
and someone came along and said hey I've
got an invention you don't have to have
laser eye surgery anymore it rests on
the ears and the bridge of your nose I
call them glasses could they have sold
those for a thousand two thousand
dollars a pair I don't know maybe but
you know there's kind of a cultural
element of saying you know like I don't
want to wear glasses you know I'd love
to be able to walk around without
relying on glasses or contacts of course
people are very athletic or spending a
lot of their time doing Athletics they
may be quite irritated to have to deal
with glasses or contacts people who have
very severe prescriptions I mean if you
wake up and you can't even really you
know you're fumbling for your glasses on
the bedside table because you have such
a strong strong prescription you can't
even see what it says on the alarm clock
next to the bed you know these are all
groups of patients who like really
change their daily lives by getting out
of glasses or contacts and taking
advantage of Lasik and in I don't know
99 of the time it's going to be like a
safe comfortable outcome for the patient
do they do Lasik on kids
um there are certain conditions uh
unusual cordial conditions where
procedures like Lasik get used but I
believe uh it's ideal to not do it on
children uh or even even young teenagers
and the reason goes back to what we were
talking about before you are much more
likely to change the shape of your eye
and therefore the prescription you need
and therefore what exactly the Lasik
would laser while you're still in those
growing years and you really want to be
able to say hey my eyeglasses
prescription has not changed in the last
two or three or five years because if
you do Lasik and then your eye keeps
changing shape then by the next year all
of a sudden the lasik's not doing you're
backing glasses again right you can do a
touch-up Lasik do a little bit more but
it's generally you know you're going to
be a happier person if you've reached
that point in your life and maybe that's
maybe that's your late teens more
commonly it's into the 20s where your
eye has stopped changing its
prescription every year you've been
steady and stable for some years and now
you do the Lasik and it could easily
last you a decade
you mentioned dry eye
get a lot of questions about dry eye and
a few years ago I think you and I were
at a meeting and someone
who is very woven in with the companies
that
build and test drugs for different
aspects of vision health said you know
what the field really needs is a
treatment that works for dry eye and I
thought dry eye like of all things like
why dry and then the more I learned
about it I realized that there are
millions and millions of people that
really suffer from dry eye and for whom
standard drops are just not working so
what underlies dry eye is it some
deficiency in the lacquer hormone glands
that produce tears for the eye and and I
think of Tears as just kind of salty
water
and I wonder if they are more than that
is there an oil in there and if we know
what's in tears why can't somebody just
manufacture something that works as well
as tears yeah you know it turns out you
know we we've got a lot of other eye
diseases
but by far the most common eye disease
and and I've been told by far the most
common eye treatment you know purchased
by anyone now granted it's almost always
over the counter things like artificial
tears is for dry eye
and uh in part that's because as we age
our
tier quantity goes down and our tier
quality goes down and so what do those
do mean
we have two different major elements to
tiers and as you alluded to one is the
salt water porn of part of the tears and
those are made primarily by the lacrimal
gland and there's a steady drip of those
tears onto the ocular surface as well as
reflexive tearing right if you get an
eyelash in your eye or or you cry your
lacrimal ground will actually squeeze
out extra salt water tears uh onto the
surface of the eye and so so that's
that's where most of the sort of wet
part is coming from but there's also
essential oils critical oils these come
from other types of glands including
glands in our eyelids called meibomian
glands and the oils form a surface over
the salt water part of the tear film
and and also intermix into the tears and
as we age we go down in the quantity of
both salt water part of our tears and
oil part of our tears but also the
quality and in particular the oil parts
uh can often be seen to be going down
more quickly
the the eye drop industry has pretty
much solved for replacing the salt water
part of your tears right you can get
either bottles of preserve preservative
containing you know you could use that
bottle all month or for a month or two
or you can buy these strips of
preservative free artificial tears which
are really basically like the salt water
components and you can use those
preservative free ones we have patients
using them every hour if they need to
right you're not going to hurt anything
with preservative free artificial tears
you just drop them in just drop them in
yeah either I as as often as you want or
need when you feel it it's exacerbated
in the world we live in uh
especially these days now with more time
on computer it turns out that when you
read including when we maybe used to
read more books than we do now but also
read on the computer or stare at the
computer screen or work on the computer
or actually just even watch the TV
I've done very careful studies you blink
less when you're doing any of those
activities
and when you blink glass you're
redistributing the tears less
effectively and you're squeezing out
less of the tears including less of the
oils as effectively as you could be when
you're blinking and so
um so between aging tier quality tier
quantity
a lot of our activities
we're kind of in this losing proposition
now now I mentioned that uh we're pretty
good at replacing the wet salty part of
our tears but actually as an industry we
haven't really figured out a
how to really effectively replace the
oily part and the oils do a few things
including when you have a layer of oil
on top of a layer of water
the water is less likely to evaporate
and so the oils help hold the tears on
the surface of your eye and so if we're
not making as many or as good oils as
part of our tear film that's uh that's
also like kind of working against the
salt water part of our tears
um so yeah as an industry as a community
uh that we haven't really figured out
how to get the oil part solved for
either by effectively replacing the oils
or
treating our eyelids in a way kind of
rejuvenating those oil glands getting
them to kind of go back to their
youthful State again you know so that
the eyes including the eyelids and the
oil glands unfortunately they're aging
just like the rest of our body so so
this is this this is one of the major
features uh is uh is dry eye and and uh
and it's tough on patients because you
feel it it's really tough because you
feel it yeah I have yet another
experience to report where when I had
the blepharitis which fortunately was
transient I also experienced it every
time I would blink I could feel the
blink and boy I'll tell you I we all
most of us take for granted uh what a
pleasure it is to not observe the
blinking of our eyes because for those I
think in last about two weeks every time
I blink I'd feel an almost sandpaper
like experience it wasn't particularly
painful but it was very uncomfortable
because it suddenly conscious of every
blink and it's very very distracting now
that resolved when the blepharitis
resolved but I can't even imagine what
it would be like to deal with that all
day long every day yeah really Dreadful
yes it really is and it and so you're
absolutely right it's a very it's one of
our really big unmet needs and and
although for most people with dry eye it
can be managed with just the regular
over-the-counter artificial teardrops
you can buy at the grocery store or over
the counter at the pharmacy for a subset
of people who have really much more
severe symptoms with the dry eye it's
it's really it's hard it's a really hard
thing to have to live with all the time
and and we Counsel on the use of Tears
we Council on the use of eyelid cleaning
like we talked about before where you
take either these eyelid scrubs or a
little dilute baby shampoo to keep those
eyelashes really clean that keeps those
oil glands functioning at their top
capacity for you uh so that you're
maximizing you know high quality cheer
production reducing inflammation is also
important whether that's inflammation
from allergy and of course a lot of
people's dry eye gets much worse in the
spring with seasonal allergies when
pollen is around if you have dust
allergies in your home uh that worsens
your symptomatic dry eye
or other forms of inflammation there's a
there's an element of dry eye that we
actually think is
inflammation kind of working against our
tear glands and and in fact some of the
prescription drops now to help combat
more severe dry eye uh are
anti-inflammatory or even low-dose
steroid types of eye drops
um so I think these are all uh sort of
Next Generation treatments I think at
the at the really Leading Edge of Next
Generation treatment is trying to better
understand the nerves on the cornea and
ocular surface and if there are ways
that we could better treat them and help
help regenerate and rejuvenate kind of
how the nerves and the and the tissue
cells are interacting underneath that
tear film and that's where for some
patients we can actually use either for
example blood serum your blood serum is
actually very rich in growth factors
and many of those growth factors it
turns out empirically are really helpful
for people with dry eye so if you're one
of those people who's been really
struggling with with dry eye you might
ask your eye care provider hey I heard
about serum tears is that something that
could help me serum tears because this
PRP is this platelet-rich plasma related
but but not the plate platelet-rich
portion at least not yet they can draw
your blood spin out all the cells you're
left with the kind of liquid part of
your blood that's the serum and then
they can dilute that with some salt
water maybe with some preservatives in
some cases yeah you could keep it in
your freezer thaw a bottle when you're
ready to use it you know each few weeks
and and then use it just like an
eyedropper bottle and those serum tears
uh actually can be very helpful for
people with with much more advanced or
severe hard to control dry eye symptoms
uh companies are really trying to figure
out hey what are the most important
parts of the the serum can we just
identify and package just the growth
factor and uh and turn that into a
product for dry eye patients and so
there's a lot of research on the ocular
surface and dry eye uh going into
um going into that space right now I'll
tell you the one other recommendation
that I always give patients
there's a fair amount of evidence that
if you're getting too much of some of
these preservative chemicals which of
course if you're going to use an eye
drop bottle for a month it should have a
preservative in it right so that you
know open the bottle and then it grows
bacteria a couple weeks later and now
you're you're you know you're using
contaminated eye drops so for bottles
it's typical to have preservatives but I
really recommend for patients if they're
using anything more than a couple drops
here and there for their dry eye control
to actually go for one of the
preservative free artificial tears they
come in lots of Brands I'm sure the
house brands at any of the pharmacies
use them too I make them too and these
are the ones that come in like strips
plastic strips and you break one off you
break off the little cap you can use as
much as you want all day you have to
throw that one out if you have anything
left over you have to throw it out at
the end of the night and the next day
break off a new one because there's no
preservatives and once you open it you
don't want bacteria to grow in that salt
water right but it's really good because
the preservatives can be very irritating
or even inflammatory to the ocular
surface to the surface of our eyes so we
really do want to if we're using more
than a drop or two
upgrade that cost a little bit more
money if they're still over the counter
upgrade yourself to the preservative
free artificial tears those are great
recommendations I'm also really
interested in this serum
thing uh because you know we're this
discussion taking place 10 years ago and
I raise PRP platelet-rich plasma there
would probably be a lot of eye rolls no
pun intended because I think myself and
a lot of other people in the let's call
the sort of standard scientific and
medical community looked at
platelet-rich plasma right alongside
stem cell therapies because they were
cheek to jowl back then as you recall
before the FDA regulations about stem
cell claims which we will get to
um of course
PRP was suggested as a source of stem
cells it turns out there are very few if
any true stem cells in PRP and yet now
as I understand it PRP is an FDA
approved protocol for injection into the
uterus injection into pretty much every
tissue and organ system of the body in
order to quote unquote rejuvenate it and
here I'm not promoting PRP and yet it is
a very common practice now in more
standard medical clinics but it started
off kind of Niche even gray Market kind
of underground it's diverged from stem
cell therapies and we're going to talk
about major modes of vision loss in a
moment
and this horrible situation that
happened down in Florida of a clinic
injecting stem cells into patients eyes
to recover vision and it actually
blinded them so we'll talk about stem
cell therapies but for the record is PRP
something that's now standard in major
optimal ophthalmic clinics excuse me
including your department at Stanford
are you drawing out blood spinning it
down taking plasma taking serum and
re-injecting it or reapplying it to
patients eyes not not yet in
Ophthalmology uh in eye clinics I I
would say we're sort of like right now
on the edge of uh groups are starting to
study that is it safe is it valuable is
it any better for certain conditions
like on the ocular surface than serum
Tears For example this sort of diluting
a patient's own own blood serum uh so so
it's being studied it's a very active
area now it turns out that this PRP
plasma has uh you know again like a high
concentration nation of growth factors
that's probably what's responsible for a
lot of the kind of quote tissue
Rejuvenation effects uh be that be they
as they may but but it's being studied
but it's definitely not a standard of
care yet uh at least in in Ophthalmology
space and and you know I think whenever
there's something really new it really
deserves to be properly studied we
talked before about you know at first
you're going to do trials where you just
test it carefully in a few people maybe
a few of the most severely effective
affected patients be really thoughtful
about uh you know the ethics of trying
out for safety then as you develop a
little understanding of the safety you
really want to eventually get to
properly controlled randomized what
people in the community often call
double blind trials but we in
Ophthalmology like to call Double masked
trials blind is a bad word
trials yeah yeah so you really want
properly controlled trials testing is it
really working thing is it really
deserve the claims that people are
making and that has not yet really come
to fruition at that level for
Ophthalmology or Eye Care yet so we've
been talking a lot about normal visual
development eye checks and some of the
more typical challenges that people have
with their vision
but we haven't yet touched on some of
the really debilitating stuff
things like glaucoma things like
retinitis Pigmentosa macular
degeneration the things that if we could
we would all avoid and yet are out there
in the world at pretty high rates you
know I'm sure you'll share with us what
those rates are
and as bad as these things are there are
ways to detect and offset their
progression so that people don't
necessarily lose their Vision so if you
could could you share with us what are
the major forms of vision loss in
childhood and in adulthood and what can
each and all of us do in order to find
out if we have one of these conditions
and therefore treat it effectively yeah
that's great you know
let's start by just
reminding ourselves what are the major
causes of vision loss and these are
going to differ where you are in the
world
but the major the number one cause of
low vision is actually refractive error
people who need glasses and especially
in other countries affordability access
can't even get glasses okay so that's
just refractive error but that's
fundamentally correctable
the next most common cause of vision
loss is cataract cataract is the
blurring the Aging of the lens inside
the eye behind the cornea we talked
about how that is responsible for
focusing light under the back of the eye
it also has to be clear enough that the
light gets through the lens
and a cataract is a normal aging process
you know as I said if we all live to 100
or 110 years old we'll all get cataracts
we'll all need cataract surgery we
actually is you know in in the eye
clinic we see cataracts years or even
decades before they're affecting your
vision in a meaningful way so that the
cataracts are forming and that's okay
but at some point they get bad enough
that it's time to take them out we've
actually solved for cataract surgery
pretty efficiently we could do a four to
eight minute surgery maybe if we're
taking our time it's 10 or 12 minutes of
surgical time take out a cataract it
works beautifully 99 point something
percent of the time we put a plastic a
clear plastic lens inside the eye
exactly where your lens used to be and
there's even lenses that can Flex or
focus light from far and near so
cataracts is fundamentally a there's
still room for improvement but there's
it's fundamentally a solved problem the
problem is is that worldwide there
aren't enough cataract surgeons there's
not access to care the Machinery or the
lenses
cost too much money in developing
countries to get out to the number of
people who would need them so it's
actually just again an access to care
cataract is a reversible treatable
easily treatable problem
but it's number two on the list of
causes of vision loss in the world
because we don't have enough access to
care we need a lot more sort of
programming around Global Ophthalmology
Global Eye Care to solve for cataract
just to bring that solution to countries
around the world
then after that you start hitting the
eye diseases that lead to what are
currently irreversible
non-reversible causes of vision loss the
number one cause of irreversible vision
loss in the world is glaucoma
so what is glaucoma glaucoma is actually
probably a little cluster or
constellation of diseases that we lump
together it's a degenerative disease
like a neurodegeneration we talk about
neurodegenerations in the brain like
Alzheimer's and Parkinson's glaucoma is
a neurodegenerative disease it happens
instead of affecting one or different
area in your brain it happens to affect
the optic nerve that connects the eye to
the brain and we need our optic nerves
to carry all the visual information from
the eye to the brain and so if your
optic nerve is degenerating in glaucoma
and I should add there are other optic
neuropathies so-called diseases of optic
nerve degeneration for example you can
get a stroke of the optic nerve you can
have an inflammatory disease like
multiple sclerosis called optic neuritis
that affects the optic nerve so you can
get other optic nerve diseases but
glaucoma is by far the most common optic
neuropathy and the problem is is just
like you know just like spinal cord
injury which is also part of the central
nervous system right the brain the
spinal cord the rat and the optic nerve
that's the central nervous system and
there's no regeneration and that's why
spinal cord injury leads to permanent
paralysis well optic nerve injury or
optic nerve degeneration unfortunately
leads to permanent vision loss so in the
case of glaucoma how do we get ahead of
that
glaucoma has two major risk factors one
is increasing age there are actually
infantile and pediatric glaucomas
unfortunately and those can be much more
aggressive much more damaging when they
present so early in kids uh in babies
and in children
most of the kind of run-of-the-mill
glaucoma usually results presents in
adulthood and even in in the Aging
adults so much more common after 50 or
60 or 70 years old increasing the other
main risk factor for glaucoma is
increasing eye pressure the eye actually
you know it stays inflated it's a
balloon it has to stay inflated we need
some amount of eye pressure to keep our
eye as a as an inflated balloon but if
the eye pressure goes too high and we
talked about this before you won't even
feel it if it slowly gets too high if
the eye pressure goes too high that
causes glaucoma and
um and that's one of the things that we
talked about you really include in a
comprehensive eye exam when you're just
getting a screening checkup at your eye
care provider at your optometrist or
ophthalmologist office they're going to
check your pressure and just as a
screening tool check to make sure it's
not too high
we can treat glaucoma today
by trying to reduce the impact of that
high pressure by lowering the eye
pressure so we have treatments for
glaucoma that Target the eye pressure we
have medications like eye drops we have
lasers that can be used inside the eye
that can also lower the eye pressure and
ultimately if we need them we also have
surgeries that can also provide an
outflow that lets the fluid out of the
eye in a controlled way so that the eye
pressure can be brought back down into
normal ranges
again the reason that glaucoma
ends up being the number one cause of
irreversible blindness in the world is
number one
we can't get those therapies everywhere
in the world the affordability of eye
drops the access to lasers or surgical
procedures Around The World Isn't equal
to what it is here and even within our
country you know people may not be
accessing Health Care effectively to get
screened for glaucoma or to get treated
for glaucoma the other big problem with
glaucoma is that it affects our
peripheral vision first and only very
late in the disease does it pinch in and
finally pinch off the center of our
vision in typical glaucomas
and that's a real problem because
we don't notice if our peripheral vision
is down you know our peripheral vision
isn't that good to begin with and if
you're driving and you can see a
pedestrian step off the sidewalk you
think your peripheral vision is fine but
actually your peripheral vision could
already start being damaged by glaucoma
and you won't notice it in regular daily
life and that's where the importance of
screening and early detection really
comes in for glaucoma
what we don't have for glaucoma we can
come back to like kind of what's The
Cutting Edge of the future in these eye
diseases what we don't have are
treatments that really Target the optic
nerve degenerative process and we can
come back and talk about that
so that's glaucoma and optic
neuropathies then the next two major
causes of currently largely irreversible
vision loss our age-related macular
degeneration
and then diabetic retinopathy now
age-related macular generation is just
like it sounds major risk factors age
it's very common and actually in the
developed world you know countries that
are more developed also countries that
have a larger Caucasian white population
it's more common in certain populations
than in others
um it actually is you know definitely a
leading cause of vision loss in the
elderly population for example in the
United States
um and uh there's two forms of macular
degeneration but they both end up
targeting the same part the same part of
the retina and the part of the retina is
really like the rods and the cones that
we talked about before the rods do your
low light vision at night time primarily
your cones do color vision and bright
light you know sort of normal lighting
that we experience you know through most
of our awake day
and in that back of the retina you can
have what's called dry macular
degeneration which is a slow thankfully
slow but slow Insidious disease that
causes the degeneration of the rods and
cones and also the support cells that
help feed the rods and cones and take
care of the rods and cons they're called
rpe cells retinal pigment epithelium
it's not really critical of course the
names of every different cell type but
these are like the the the light
collecting cells in our eyes in the
retina and they degenerate in macular
degeneration and in the dry form there's
this slow degeneration but some percent
of people with the dry form of macular
generation will actually convert to
What's called the wet form it's called
wet because new blood vessels actually
grow inappropriately under and even into
the retina and new blood vessels unlike
our mature blood vessels tend to be
leaky and so now the flu fluid leaks out
of those blood vessels gets into the
retina interferes with vision and that
can lead to a much more acute loss of
vision now we have some treatments for
wet macular degeneration we have
injections that can go into the eye that
actually fight against the molecules
that are causing those new blood vessels
to grow and these are antibodies that
can be injected into the eye and they
can be very effective controlling
patients wet macular degeneration
it's been a much bigger uphill battle
even over the last decade as advances
are being made to to really try to knock
back or or slow down even the dry form
of macular degeneration there was just
some exciting news even just in the last
few months the first uh successful
Trials of a treatment for the dry form
uh have just shown success and properly
randomized controlled human clinical
trials phase three clinical trials so
it's an exciting time
those new treatments are not going to be
a Panacea they slow the progression like
the an anatomic progression of the
disease
uh maybe by 20 or 25 so so patients are
still going to get worse even with those
treatments so there's still a lot more
to be done to really knock back macular
degeneration I want to mention you
mentioned retinitis Pigmentosa that's
like an inherited form of a type of
macular degeneration it's also affecting
the rods and cones and also the support
cells the rpe cells in the back of the
eye retinized Pigmentosa is an inherited
form
there are actually many different genes
you could have that could leave to
retinized pigments Pigmentosa in
aggregate if you add up all the people
with all those different genes uh and it
can be very devastating because it can
really affect the vision knock out your
vision very early in life including in
children and even versions of that and
babies but you add that all up it's
still much less common in aggregate than
macular degeneration
but in a way it's you know quite a bit
more severe because it does affect
people much earlier in life so so I sort
of Clump those together macular
degeneration retinitis Pigmentosa
degeneration of the rods and cones and
the support cells the rpe support cells
and then you you can't have this part of
the discussion about what are the
devastating eye diseases without
bringing up diabetic retinopathy
especially because diabetes
unfortunately really continues to grow
in especially let's say in the United
States certainly in the developed world
you know as we
um especially type 2 diabetes with
eating habits exercise habits
contributing to a proliferation of some
of the risk factors for type 2 diabetes
metabolic syndrome obesity
we're unfortunately seeing a
proliferation a growth in the number of
people with diabetes and with the growth
in diabetes unfortunately comes the
growth of the complications of diabetes
and one of the major complications of
diabetes is damage to the retina inside
the eye and we call that diabetic
retinopathy and there again some of the
same
damage that occurs
especially when in diabetes again some
new blood vessels are growing or blood
vessels are leaky some of that can be
treated with it used to be lasers and
now more commonly is often being treated
with some of the same injectable drugs
that are treating macular degeneration
um but there's still a lot of vision
loss with diabetes and diabetic
retinopathy I think that's an area where
again early screening making sure if you
have diabetes that's that's an
indication where you definitely have to
be going in and getting your at least
annual exam with an eye care provider or
having someone take a photograph of the
inside of your eye and rate that
photograph to say if you have any
diabetic retinopathy or not
in terms of interventions can we talk
about diabetic retinopathy first because
of course type 1 diabetes is a failure
to produce insulin relatively rare
compared to type 2 diabetes which as you
mentioned is proliferating in developing
countries right this is probably
unprecedented in the sense that
developing countries have better Medical
Care typically than non-developed
countries
more opportunities for food nourishment
and yet it's clearly a problem of
overnourishment insulin insensitivity
obesity Etc
is this type of diabetic retinopathy
that one observes the same for type 1
diabetics versus type 2 diabetics
because my understanding is that type 2
diabetes this insulin insensitivity is
a bit of a Continuum right I mean the
type 1 diabetes is as far as I know is
all or none you either make insulin or
you don't but type 2 diabetes someone
could be mildly in insulin insensitive
or severely insulin insensitive and
sometimes I'm told people are not
necessarily obese and can have type 2
diabetes as well certainly things like
smoking and alcohol intake can
contribute to that so how equivalent are
type 1 and type 2 diabetes when framed
Under the Umbrella of diabetic
retinopathy yeah the the time to
presentation can be different
a type 1 diabetic usually presents with
sort of a
cataclysmic sudden loss sudden sort of
final loss of their ability to make
insulin it usually presents in childhood
or teenage years but can present you can
have late onset type 1 diabetes because
it's kind of a sudden presentation it
can take some years after that to show
any diabetic retinopathy whereas just
because just just like you said type 2
diabetes can be on a Continuum and
people can have like kind of a mild type
2 diabetes but kind of be you know
getting along you know going through
life kind of maybe not even realizing
you know at first and so when you're
diagnosed with type 2 diabetes you've
probably had some insulin resistance for
the years prior to your diagnosis and so
in that case you often can have
um you know like you're you're at higher
risk for presenting sooner with the
complications of diabetes like diabetic
retinopathy now given that the actual
retinopathy
is very similar maybe the same uh
between type 1 diabetes and type 2
diabetes and again it involves things
like leaky blood vessels new blood
vessel growth there's some amount of
neurodegenerative dysfunction that just
simply occurs uh so so uh you can have
little little hemorrhages or bleeding
spots in the retina tiny little strokes
or microvascular uh events in the retina
so that can happen in either type 1 or
type 2 diabetes once you start having
the retinopathy it does look pretty
similar
so what can people do to prevent or
treat diabetic retinopathy obviously the
type 1 diabetic needs to take insulin in
order to survive really type 2 diabetics
need to get their obesity under control
if they are in fact obese and get their
blood sugar levels under control
regardless that's my understanding and
by extension are you seeing any
reductions in diabetic retinopathy with
people that are taking these glucose
like peptide mimics like ozempic which
is used to treat type 2 diabetes yeah
it's been a very exciting development
for the diabetes field this new class of
of um of
anti-diabetic drugs and
um so uh there you've touched on a
couple of them there are a few key
things for reducing the risk of diabetes
or the impact of an diabetes on your
retina at risk of diabetic retinopathy
or impact of diabetes on your retina
uh one is as I mentioned get regular eye
exams be screened you know any diabetic
should be screened at least once a year
uh with a with a good comprehensive
retinal exam looking for any of these uh
items the number one most important
element to prevent diabetic retinopathy
is to control your diabetes and having a
real good blood sugar control keeping
your hemoglobin A1c which is one of the
blood tests that gets used to measure
how your kind of long-term diabetes
management is going
uh that's really uh you know first and
foremost the most important and that's
been shown in large clinical trials they
actually randomize patients to hey take
care of your diabetes or do a real good
job taking care of your diabetes and the
patients who did a real good job taking
care of their diabetes have much less
diabetic retinopathy so that's number
one it turns out that if you have high
blood pressure and diabetes that blood
pressure is also really damaging to your
retina also by the way the kidneys and
probably all the other organs that are
suffering from the diabetic insult so in
addition to controlling blood sugar
really important to have blood pressure
under great control now both blood sugar
and blood pressure in type 2 diabetics
especially if you're catching them early
can be improved with some of these you
know so-called Lifestyle Changes like
improving eating watching what your food
intake is you know getting good exercise
trying to lose weight uh so these are
definitely on that list of how do you
get to good blood sugar and blood
pressure control
but suffice it to say blood sugar and
blood pressure control right at the top
and then also including the regular at
least annual exams and then if diabetic
retinopathy is detected and blood sugar
and blood pressure control are not going
to be enough for that patient we do have
treatments as I mentioned before there
are drugs that can be injected if your
retina is getting you know kind of leaky
blood vessels from diabetes there are
treatments that we can give the eye
specifically to try to counter the
diabetic retinopathy terrific in terms
of glaucoma as you mentioned glaucoma is
related to pressure although there is
pressure normal glaucoma
glaucoma is a death of the retinal
ganglion cells the neurons that connect
the eye to the brain and once they are
gone at least at this point in human
history they can't be replaced although
hopefully because of work that you've
done in the other Laboratories are doing
at some point that statement I just made
will not be true in the rgcs can be
replaced
meanwhile what can and should people do
to find out if they have glaucoma
and to treat glaucoma
and is it true that even if somebody has
normal pressure that lowering their eye
pressure further protects them against
glaucoma yeah that's absolutely right so
most important is to get screened with a
formal exam at your optometrist or
ophthalmologist because you you won't
notice you won't have any symptoms if
your eye pressure is too high you won't
know you're not likely to notice until
very late in the disease if your
peripheral vision is being damaged
through the course of glaucoma so most
important us have a screening exam a
good comprehensive screening exam will
always include checking the eye
pressures and also looking in the back
of your eye the head of the optic nerve
where all the fibers leave the eye and
carry the optic nerve information back
to the brain we can see that when we
look inside your eye and uh and and
glaucoma has a fairly characteristic
look to it in the optic nerve head so so
looking at the optic nerve had uh we
have Imaging and peripheral vision
testing that can also be included in
those screening exams so if you really
get a comprehensive screening exam you
can very reliably detect if you have
glaucoma to worry about or you're in the
clear
if you have glaucoma to worry about we
have treatments and you're absolutely
right whether you start with a
abnormally high pressure or you start
with a pressure that's on the face of it
in the normal range
in either case lowering the pressure has
been shown in large properly controlled
clinical trials to slow the progression
of optic nerve damage and vision loss so
absolutely in either case starting with
high pressure or starting with normal
pressure in either case you've got to
lower the pressure further and as I
mentioned we have eye drops those are
usually the first line there's very good
data that there's a very benign
non-invasive laser it's not the same
kind of laser that gets used for Lasik
but there's a benign very safe type of
laser called selective laser
trabeculoplasty SLT we call it and
that's also very effective as a first
line actually in the largest clinical
trial from which the data have been
coming out just even over the last few
years it's called the light trial in the
light trial patients with glaucoma were
randomly assigned to either get the
laser or the sort of most common first
strongest eye drop and uh that gets used
clinically and actually
on many features they both worked at
least as well but when looking out over
the long term actually the laser had
some advantages over the eye drop not in
the least of which by the way it's very
nice for patients to not have to like
remember to use the eye drop every night
and so um so that's quite helpful I
think uh to to keep in mind as a
treatment option uh early in the course
of the disease of course if the eye
drops under our lasers are not enough
early in the disease we also have
surgical approaches to lower the eye
pressure further you know even with all
of our treatments all of these
treatments stepping patients through all
of this
about 10 15 even 20 percent of patients
will lose very meaningful functional
vision and maybe five ten fifteen
percent of patients especially depending
where you are in the world will go blind
from glaucoma
including in you know quote-unquote
developed countries uh there's still a
very significant cohort of patients that
go blind legally blind and then you know
absolute blindness I can't even tell if
the lights are on in the room uh so it's
it's it's it's devastating it's
Insidious it's hard to detect early
um and so glaucoma's still a tough one
even with all of the treatments that we
have okay so get your pressures checked
folks and if you are prescribed drops
take your drops
I hear about patients not taking their
drops which to me just seems like
baffling but I guess having to do
something day in and day out is it can
be Troublesome enough that unless people
are losing their Vision very quickly or
they are very afraid of losing their
Vision sometimes they just neglect to
take them it's hard it's hard for
glaucoma eye drops it's hard for taking
your blood pressure medication it's hard
for a lot of medicines you know if
you're if you're taking a medicine where
you don't feel better you know if you
have a headache and you take an aspirin
or Tylenol or an ibuprofen uh you know
you feel better you feel reinforced gosh
taking that pill made sense right but if
you're using an eye drop that like hey
this is going to protect you for the
next 20 years from losing your vision
but you don't notice every day that
anything's better and by the way the eye
drops could be a little irritating maybe
it stings a little for a minute or two
and you put it in your eye some people
are even less tolerant of the eye drops
it's hard to feel motivated every day
and we know that we call that compliance
we know that it's very hard for patients
to stay compliant with prescribed
medications where they don't feel or
notice a difference in a daily way
I realize that we can't stop aging
yet
um but right now you can't stop aging
and age is a risk factor for glaucoma my
understanding is so is smoking or vaping
nicotine
and so is alcohol
and by that reasoning should people
strive to drink less and smoke less
including vaping nicotine less if they
are concerned about glaucoma yeah and
not just glaucoma macular degeneration
actually macular degeneration has a
couple major risk factors macular
degeneration aging just like with
glaucoma major risk factor
smoking including exposure to secondhand
smoke major risk factor for macular
degeneration and for the progression and
vision loss potentially associated with
macular degeneration in the case of
macular degeneration there's also a
couple of genes that we've sequenced the
human genome and there's a couple of
genes associated with magnet generation
two
that's less true for your typical
run-of-the-mill adult Kuma there are
genes for the Pediatric and infantile
forms of glaucoma uh so yeah smoking a
hundred percent including vaping uh it's
a No-No for your eyes just like it's a
No-No for the rest of your body and uh
it's tough as the eye doctor to have
these conversations with patients
because you kind of feel like well you
know they must know it already and I'm
trying to be the good guy in the room
with the patient convince them to use
their other medications but it's it's
important for us also as Eye Care
Providers to reinforce the message with
our patients a smoking terrible idea uh
for maca degeneration also for glaucoma
you know glaucoma is interesting because
the optic nerve where it degenerates
kind of right at the head of the optic
nerve where it exits the eye it's what
we call a watershed Zone it's kind of an
edge of two blood vessel supplies and if
either of those blood vessels supplies
are a little bit short on blood or
oxygen supply to that optic nerve head
your glaucoma is going to get worse your
optic nerve is going to be under fed and
that's going to worsen this degenerative
process just by not having all the right
nutrients and oxygen so the other thing
is that especially for glaucoma
everything that we talk about for being
heart healthy
for the rest of our body is is almost
certainly true for glaucoma and so I
also always counsel glaucoma patients
it's not just no smoking but eat healthy
have a multivitamin uh get some exercise
all those things that are good for your
cardiovascular system are going to be
good for your eyes in general and in
particular if you have glaucoma or at
risk high risk for glaucoma I realize
that smoking or vaping are problematic
for glaucoma and for macular
degeneration but we can't have a
conversation about glaucoma without at
least mentioning cannabis I did an
entire episode about cannabis which
touched on some of the real dangers of
very high THC concentration cannabis
this lost me a few
um followers I'm sure no problem because
what was important was to convey the
fact that the Cannabis that's out there
nowadays comes in a variety of different
strains and ratios of THC to CBD there's
some severe risks of high THC especially
in young males although not always the
point being that there are and I want to
be very clear about this because for
whatever reason cannabis gets people
really up in arms they always say it's
not as bad as alcohol but guess what we
did an entire episode about alcohol and
there the message is very clear zero is
better than any and two a week is
probably the limit and if you're an
alcoholic zero is the rule so
with cannabis it's clear by my read of
the data that it can lower eye pressure
which may undermine the progression of
glaucoma somewhat but if people are
smoking that cannabis is it therefore
going to offset any gain that one would
get from that cannabis and then how does
one account for the potentially
problematic aspects of very high THC
cannabis yeah it's a great question and
the truth is is that in most patients
cannabis will lower the eye pressure the
problem is is it really only lowers that
eye pressure During the period that
you're high from the Cannabis and the
second problem is that smoking version
of getting that cannabis into your
system the smoking is bad for your lungs
by the way the smoke from Cannabis or
from cigarettes is also terrible for
your dry eyes it causes inflammation it
dries out your eyes so it's also very
bad from that perspective now so the the
problem with cannabis is not that it
doesn't work to lower the price we want
to lower the pressure that's great the
problem with cannabis is that it's not
realistic for most of our patients
to prescribe could you go out and be
high from Cannabis 24 hours a day seven
days a week for the next 20 years I'm
sure some people have tried and
succeeded
um but right that's not practical for
most people and certainly for young
people it could be really especially
problematic yeah I should say absolutely
so so I recommend not taking that
approach but that said I I'm definitely
not a decryer of it and now that there
are edible forms I certainly have
patients who are using it in a
responsible way uh especially edible
forms and uh and in select cases like
that could make the difference for them
helping to keep the pressure down and
I'll say for example you know it turns
out you've talked a lot over the last
couple years about diurnal curves and
circadian rhythms it turns out that our
eye pressure also undergoes a circadian
rhythm and it's actually highest at
night while we're sleeping kind of peaks
in those early morning hours then hits a
low throughout the early day and then
kind of rises again throughout the
afternoon into the evening and we have a
lot of patients who they come into their
Clinic visit their eye pressure looks
normal but it's actually quite a bit
higher when they're at home and that
could explain some fraction of what we
call normal pressure glaucoma it just
looks normal during the day it's
actually high at night and so in
particular some patients I certainly
have some patients who are using these
products like let's say before bed and
if it's controlling their eye pressure
at night while they're asleep when the
eye pressure would have been the highest
it may confer some protective advantage
over time but that said again like for
most patients it's not going to be the
primary approach I'm most excited about
the idea of
you know Laboratories or companies
figuring out which
the compounds Within These cannabinoids
they're called within these products are
actually responsible for lowering the
eye pressure and could we get like a
more potent eye specific
long-acting drug that's basically
derived from the concept of cannabis but
works better and is more compatible with
not bringing along all the other adverse
elements that can come with cannabis use
you mentioned the Circadian rhythm and
eye pressure and the fact that eye
pressure is higher at night
is there any advantage to sleeping in a
particular position I know this might
sound a little detailed but I seem to
recall an abstract or a paper a few
years ago at a meeting that you and I
both attended were that said that if
people slept with their head below their
feet eye pressures were higher than if
their head was slightly elevated above
their feet and for somebody who has
glaucoma this could make a pretty
substantial difference in terms of their
eye pressures at precisely the hours of
the night we should say in which they
could be doing the most damage to the
ganglion cells yeah absolutely and we
will sometimes counsel patients with
severe glaucoma especially if they're
you know poorly responsive to standard
therapies or poorly able to tolerate
standard therapies we'll counsel them if
they're able to sleep up on a couple
pillows get kind of a 30 degree sleep
angle going what I don't want to do is
interfere with a person's sleep because
I just I fundamentally feel for the
total health of the whole human being
getting a good night's sleep is maybe
more important than that 30 degrees and
if trying to sleep up on pillows at 30
degrees it's going to lead to kind of
restless difficult sleep night I'd
rather the patient get a good night's
sleep but if they can tolerate it and
especially if they have a sort of a
tough version of glaucoma then we'll
we'll let them try see if they can sleep
up the other really interesting question
that arises is uh does which side you
sleep on affect uh which I might have
worse glaucoma glaucoma is almost always
with with a few rare exceptions almost
always a disease of two eyes but it can
present very asymmetrically in fact it's
quite common to have one eye kind of
have worse damage than the other and and
we don't know fundamentally why that is
but one hypothesis was gosh maybe if you
sleep on the right eye uh then your
right eye will have worse glaucoma
because the pressure is a little higher
down below or maybe it's pressing on the
pillow in a way or some something like
that there have been a couple studies
really really looking at that question a
couple Studies have said the lower aisle
have worse glaucoma a couple Studies
have said the higher I will have worse
glaucoma so the upshot is it probably
doesn't matter which side you sleep on
we also know when you video people in
their normal sleep pattern even if you
feel you always fall asleep on the left
side of your face people toss and turn
all night probably over the course of
the night you're spending a similar
amount of time on each eye I'm glad you
brought up that point in terms of
macular degeneration I'm curious about
the things that people can do as opposed
to the don'ts in order to perhaps offset
macular degeneration one of the things
that I'm intrigued by are the results of
Glenn Jeffery's laboratory over at
University College London I had known
Jeff for probably a decade or more and
he typically worked on animal models but
then a few years ago started publishing
studies I believe there are now two
published studies showing how red light
exposure
and near infrared
light exposure done early in the day to
the eye at a distance of about two feet
for just a couple of minutes a few times
a week could offset some of the vision
loss associated with age-related macular
degeneration in people older than 40.
that's my understanding of these studies
and there's a theory there about
enhancing function of mitochondria and
photoreceptors by reducing reactive
oxygen species there's a whole
mechanistic hypothesis but
my question is is that the sort of
protocol that produces significant
enough offset of macular degeneration
like we should all be looking at red
lights in the morning
um or is it still too early days in
order to really conclude that
data is very compelling the data are
very compelling that this kind of red or
near infrared light therapy can be at
some level neuroprotective and yes uh
the the data suggests that uh kind of
ramping up high high functioning
mitochondria is a part of that
activating neuroprotective Pathways in
the retina it's actually been
demonstrated in animal models and a
little human data here and there but
both for macular degeneration kind of uh
degenerative is but also for optic
neuropathies you know like glaucoma
retinal ganglion cells the cells that
carry all that visual information from
the eye to the brain they're chock full
of mitochondria too and uh and so the
idea that this could be a therapeutic
approach I think is very compelling
there are a number of studies actually I
think still ongoing today
really trying to figure out what's the
right dose how much brightness do you
need is there an optimal wavelength how
many minutes does it matter when during
the day you provide that light or how
many minutes or hours
um these are still very much open
questions you know what's the dose
what's the delivery
um but it's it's it's it's it's very
promising looking and there's biological
premise and I'm excited to see where
that goes because again that's like a
that's a very accessible uh sort of
therapeutic approach that could be
brought to a very broad swath of of
people so I'm excited about that sorry I
didn't mean to interrupt and completely
non-invasive
um I should um probably mention a
warning which is if people are going to
decide that they're going to jump on
this result and do red light exposure in
the early part of the day no matter what
color a light is if it's too bright you
can damage your eye so I think this is
why you're pointing the fact that we
need established protocol calls before
people really start blasting their eyes
with red light and if they are going to
expose themselves to Red Light it
shouldn't be uncomfortably bright do I
have that yeah that's absolutely right
you know actually uh light effect
um we talked about this a little bit
earlier
um there's actually now data also that
red light and actually interestingly
studies using light at the other end of
the visible spectrum violet light either
of those in small daily doses can also
be used to prevent progression of
nearsightedness in children in
school-aged children and so I think
we're really just on the cusp of really
understanding the biology of how these
different light therapies might be
leveraged maximally to to maximize our
Eye Health and both during development
and at the other end of the spectrum as
we age so it's an exciting area and I
think this kind of phototherapy is uh
you know a very hot topic for research
right now very hot topic one has to
wonder whether or not these light
therapies the fact that infrared works
and maybe ultraviolet works is are
really just capturing some of what
sunlight
is naturally doing when as you mentioned
before a child or perhaps an adult also
spends a certain number of hours
outdoors I mean maybe we're just filling
in the blanks that are neglected
nowadays because we're spending so much
time indoors under artificial lights and
in front of screens yeah yeah
very thoughtful possibility yeah
I have a couple of we don't have to call
them quick questions but common
questions that perhaps have a brief uh
explanations uh for instance I put out a
request for questions in an anticipation
of this episode and I got a lot of
people asking what are floaters in the
eye and is there anything that people
can do to get rid of floaters yeah our
eye when we're born is actually filled
in the middle of it with a jelly it's
not just fluid it's kind of a jelly
there's collagen fibers and thankfully
the whole jelly is largely invisible so
the light can get through our eye back
to the retina without being impeded as
we age those different fibers and gels
shrink and contract and they peel off of
the back of the retina so there's just
in the middle now your your eyeball
doesn't shrink because it fills in with
with fluid with salt water basically but
the gel part shrinks and as it shrinks
and also pulls peels off the retina it
can pull off kind of little tiny retinal
bits not important to your vision bits
but just like little tissue bits and
also as it congeals it kind of uh can
get little concretions in the jelly and
we perceive those as floaters you know
little almost semi-translucent or in
some cases kind of grayish blackish
sometimes sometimes you get a big one if
it peels off the edge of the optic nerve
in the back of the eye as happens we
call that a posterior vitreous
detachment you can actually see like a
moon or a half moon floater in Your
Vision these are very frustrating to a
lot of people
um and uh the good news is in almost all
cases they will just go away by
themselves in theory it's been played
with gosh we could do like a big surgery
to chew up all that jelly replace it all
with salt water try to get rid of your
floaters there's risk associated with
that surgery we use it very effective
actively in a retinal detachments or
other diseases bad diabetic retinopathy
bleeding inside the eye we can take out
the jelly from the eye replace it with
with salt water but that's not
um you know putting patients through the
risk of that surgery just to get rid of
a couple of floaters or a few floaters
that probably are going to go away over
the next few months I actually like to
tell patients it's nothing to worry
about just ignore them and actually if
you stop focusing on them your brain
will actually start filtering them out
you'll stop noticing them if you can
kind of uh not worry about them be a
little intentional about ignoring them
in the beginning and then they do
actually go away and look some will go
away these three will go away these two
will appear eventually you'll stop
having floaters most patients will stop
having floaters so we really don't like
to put a patient at risk by intervening
we really like to in this case just
reassure them it's going to be okay just
ignore them they'll eventually go away
thank you for that answer
twitching of the eye is something that
people complain about I know when I get
tired I'll get a twitch over one eye I
think there's a condition is it called
myasthena gravis where people go through
a stressful period or get very fatigued
and I think that's a depletion of the
nerve terminal communication between the
nerves that control the muscles of the
eye and then people get this kind of
like hooded eye look
um where they have a hard time opening
their eyes but barring something extreme
like myasthena gravis
or staying up for two days working or
even just being a bit sleep deprived
what causes the twitching of the eyelid
and is there anything people can do
about that most the time it's actually
just a bad nerve ending you know maybe
that one nerve cell you know your eyelid
is fed by you know hundreds maybe it's
thousands of nerve cells that are doing
the muscles they're doing the feeling
obviously if the ones controlling the
muscles that can lead to a twitch if one
of those nerve cells kind of just starts
you know maybe that one nerve cell is
dying just you know whatever the age you
can process uh you know it happens in
young people too though so you got one
bad fiber that's just deciding to kind
of ring off the hook that's that's that
telephone's just ringing off the hook
and it's just activating the muscle so
you're just twitching that muscle I've
had them as well and you can have
notches in your eyelids you can have
this anywhere in your body like one
little spot on your leg where just the
muscle right under the skin again is
just
and typically it'll happen over the
course of a couple of months
intermittently some days more sometimes
less maybe it correlates with when
you're tired a little bit sometimes and
then it'll stop that nerve cell will
either reconnect properly and stop doing
that maybe it dies we don't really know
but typically it lasts on that scale now
there are other diseases not just
myasthenia gravis you can have blepharos
spasm like where you have a chronic
spasming of of certain nerves causing
muscles to spasm and there we we can use
we can use treatments for example Botox
as a treatment that you know people use
for cosmetic reducing of wrinkles for
example but you know a really good
medical use of Botox is preventing that
blepharospasm and patients can come in
once every three or six months if they
have a really severe spasming version of
what you're describing but the regular
occasional run-of-the-mill lasts a
couple months nothing to worry about it
does not pre-sage anything bad happening
in your future and maybe let it run its
course and you'll be okay great
we've all heard that carrots are good
for our vision which presumably stems
from some peripheral understanding about
the fact that vitamin A is integral to
the photosynthesis pathway of converting
light into electrical and chemical
signals that the rest of the eye brain
can use and yet I'm guessing that there
probably aren't that many people walking
around who are vitamin A deficient
they're probably out there but not that
many especially in developed countries
and in addition in the last really five
years but in particular in the last two
years I've seen a proliferation of
supplements on the market to promote Eye
Health and Longevity of vision
I'd love your thought on this General
theme of nutrition and supplements for
improving Eye Health or for maintaining
Eye Health and before we started
recording you mentioned that
Ophthalmology or at least Eye Health is
one area of medicine that has a bit not
extensive but a bit of a longer history
of exploring supplementation in rigorous
randomized control trials whereas other
areas of Neuroscience and Neural Health
such as Alzheimer's Etc certainly there
are brain health supplements out there
but there aren't a lot of rigorous data
to support them just yet so what are
your thoughts on nutrition
um aside from the standard thing of you
know people shouldn't be ingesting too
many calories such that they are obese
and diabetic and therefore you know Etc
indirect effects of nutrition
um what are your thoughts on nutrition
and supplementation for Eye Health yeah
you know you're absolutely right and
again in Ophthalmology we actually do
have quite a bit of studies there's been
quite a bit of attention over the years
even over the decades looking at this
question and I think it's worth
highlighting
um a couple of yeses and a couple of
no's
for macular degeneration which we talked
about being an exceedingly common cause
of vision loss there have been two
age-related eye disease studies called
arids age-related eye disease studies
era there is arids and then arids too
and those studies were a large
randomized Trials of using giving giving
patients supplements and in arids it was
vitamin c and e
uh higher dose than would just come in a
multivitamin
zinc and copper
and then also beta-carotene
and beta-carotene is one of these what
are called carotenoids it's a it's a if
you look at the extended family there's
maybe 600 different chemical entities of
these carotenoids and beta-carotene is
one of them that's in the direct pathway
of making vitamin A and so that was the
principle in the Arid study and the Arid
studies showed that patients randomized
to these pills compared to controls it
it did these are antioxidants in part
right in addition to feeding into that
vitamin A pathway and um and the
patients randomized to get that
supplement mixture
showed less progression of their dry
macular degeneration in the moderate to
severe ranges if you had mild macular
degeneration they didn't show a
statistically significant Improvement
but I will say it's my experience you
know myself with patients and and seeing
how the field works you know if you have
mild macular degeneration even though
it's not as clinically proven we're
still often recommending hey if you can
afford that supplement go ahead and buy
that now arids Was Then followed by a
second study arids too also with vitamin
C vitamin E zinc and copper they
actually tested whether a slightly lower
dose of zinc would be as good as a
higher dose and a lower dose was as good
as a higher dose and then instead of the
beta-carotene they tested against the
beta-carotene they tried two other
carotenoids that are called lutein and
zeaxanthine and and they actually found
head to head that the second the arids
II formula without the beta-carotene and
with the lutein and zeaxanthin that that
formula was even better at slowing dry
macro degeneration in the moderate to
severe population again it's not clear
how much it may help mild back the
generation but in the uh sort of
clinically defined moderate towards
severe group there was a statistically
significant it reduced it by about 20 25
the progression of your dry Market
generation and you know over a couple of
years 25 five percent you may not notice
but over a couple of decades you know
that could really slow down the
progression of your disease
now it turns out that the beta carotene
they noted a little bit of an increased
cancer risk in the patients in the arids
one who had that beta-carotene mostly in
patients who are smokers
they also noticed in the second one that
if you were already not taking a
multivitamin or not eating a diet that's
already naturally rich in lutein or
zeaxanthin that the effect of that
supplement was even stronger
so it was very strong clinical trial
support for taking what we now use this
arids II supplementation and I'm sure we
can list the formula or put it in the
links under under your podcast uh uh
that that thus really does slow macular
degeneration so that's like a very
strong example of a yes you should do
this
there's one yes brewing in the glaucoma
field right now and that's high dose
vitamin B3 B is in boy three it's also
called in its various forms either
nicotinic acid or nicotinamide uh the
nicotin sounds like nicotine but this is
not a substitute for smoking or vaping
this is a different this is a vitamin
that just has a very similar sounding
name it's in the NAD synthesis pathway
that's exactly right it's in the NAD
pathway NAD is one of the oxidative
stress regulators and energy Regulators
of our cells so it's a very critical
molecule in the metabolism of our cells
and there was very strong evidence in
pre-clinical models of mice given
glaucoma that manipulating this pathway
and sort of increasing this pathway
could be protective in glaucoma or other
optic neuropathies optic nerve
degenerative diseases and so there have
now been been too limited but randomized
controlled clinical trials one looking
at glaucoma patients looking at their
visual field so their actual visual
performance and the other looking at the
electrical signals in the eye called an
electroretnogram kind of like an EEG
does for your brain we can do an ERG for
your retina and in both of those trials
high-dose vitamin B3 was a found to be
very safe and B was shown to actually
improve at least in the short term
improve retinal function measured either
on visual field testing or on the
electro retinogram now this is now
entering
clinical trials large kind of phase 3
style clinical trials actually around
the world it's a very hot topic for
glaucoma the fact that this NAD boosting
supplementation with high-dose vitamin
B3 might be a great approach to helping
protect the nerve in in glaucoma and so
as I say there's there's three or four
large randomized phase three style
clinical trials uh starting now and so
over the next year or two we'll get more
data but I'll tell you like I have
patience and if they're at the end of
their rope and we are having a lot of
trouble controlling their vision loss
from glaucoma I'm already recommending
in these limited cases uh hey why don't
you try this it's almost certainly safe
and it may and it may help and it may
help protect your vision over time so so
that's that's an area that's kind of
another like kind of could be a yes
early data's point in the right
direction you want to be careful but uh
but I but I am starting to recommend it
at the same time that we're actually
doing the clinical trials now that said
there are a lot of other things that
people talk about other supplements
ginkgo biloba things with generic names
on the internet like you know glaucoma
preservation you know uh yeah that sort
of thing makes my uh gives me hives you
know yeah and these are areas where
there might be scientific premise like a
plausible explanation for how this
should help but not good data that it
actually helps thankfully in most cases
these things are safe uh but I just
worry about patience
hitching their wagon to something that's
not going to help them getting their
hopes up uh worst case scenario not
taking their actually proven prescribed
treatments and instead using an
alternative therapy that doesn't have
data to support it and so I think there
there's a lot of you know
um uh you know either unfounded
unsupported uh you know information it
travels around chat rooms travels around
the internet one person tells the next
person you know there's inappropriate
advertising for some of these uh and
they're you know I really don't want
patients to be hurt not necessarily hurt
by taking something that's not helping
but but maybe hurt by feeling like I
don't have to go to the doctor I'm
taking this supplement and that would be
obviously a really bad potential outcome
for a patient yeah I completely agree
supplements are just as the name
suggests a supplement to an already
hopefully healthy lifestyle and use of
medication where it's prescribed and
I've often said on the podcast that
sometimes the best dose of a supplement
is zero milligrams so I do appreciate
you touching on those themes because
um supplementation is something that
comes up from time to time on the
podcast and I know that I've certainly
have seen a number of these different I
Envision support supplements we aren't
affiliated with any of them I don't
personally take any of them but these
clinical trials sound promising so I'm
going to keep an ear to the ground for
them
as a final question and hopefully a
topic that we can cover in more detail
in a subsequent episode of the podcast
because I absolutely want to have you
back to discuss this in more detail
I'd like to just get your thoughts on
the fact that the neural retina is in
fact neural and it's part of the brain
and we are hearing an increasing amount
of positive chatter about the use of
Imaging the eye and the retina directly
as a way to detect other forms of
neurodegeneration for those that are
listening or for watching
um you know I'm putting my hands up in
kind of C shape at the back of your eye
is lined with these with this three cell
layer thick thing that is the neural
retina which are really pieces of brain
that connect to the rest of the brain
and because it resides in the eyes and
outside the cranial Vault people like
you
skilled clinicians with the appropriate
tools can look into the eye and see the
brain directly without having to cut
through the skull
and my understanding is that more and
more ophthalmologists are seeing
cases where degeneration of the retina
is correlated with degeneration of
structures deeper in the brain making
Imaging of the neural retina perhaps one
of the best diagnostic tools for
predicting and tracking the progression
of Alzheimer's and other forms of
neurodegeneration do I have that right
yeah absolutely actually this is a super
exciting area you know we we have this
long-standing sang in Ophthalmology that
the eye is a window to the brain the
eyes of window to the soul of course is
a log standing sang right and and it
turns out that you know in Alzheimer's
disease as an example you know we really
talk a lot about the degeneration of
basal forebrain cholinergic neurons that
are leading to the cognitive deficits in
Alzheimer's disease but it turns out
that there is also some degeneration
throughout other areas of the brain
including the retina and since we have
such a relatively easy time Imaging the
retina you can go into your doctor's
office and get a quick little sort of
laser scan of the retina a picture of
the ratna compared to like going through
a full MRI processor for your brain
and we can detect the degeneration of
the retina and optic nerve associated
with Alzheimer's disease it looks like
the same thing is happening in
Parkinson's disease in Ms now one of the
issues is that in a lot of these
degenerative diseases were able to
detect the difference in the retina but
were not necessarily able to say hey if
we see this in the retina it's multiple
sclerosis but if we see that in the
retina it's Alzheimer's disease so there
may not be there may be good sensitivity
to detecting the disease and to
following whether your diseases your
brain disease is getting worse but there
may not be very good specificity
differentiating the different diseases
and I say that with a very big asterisk
at the end of that sentence because
there's actually amazingly cool new data
one of our colleagues who you know Alf
dubra
has helped revolutionize a new way of
Imaging the retina that's giving us now
cellular resolution and even subcellular
resolution seeing things smaller than
the sizes of cells inside our retina and
recently in one of his projects he's
teamed up with another one of our
faculty Heather Moss she's a
neuro-ophthalmologist so she really
specializes clinically in the eye brain
connection and her research focuses on
that and together they made actually an
amazing recent discovery of very
specialized unusual novel structures
that they can detect in the retina of
patients with multiple sclerosis and
whether these kinds of discoveries or
other similar kinds of discoveries are
going to lead to kind of a a whole new
generation of biomarkers which are ways
of measuring disease diagnosing who has
the disease figuring out who's getting
worse from the disease figuring out
who's responding to therapies that we're
trying to use to treat the diseases this
is a very exciting area and this really
touches on what we're all hoping is the
future of of eye care as well as the
rest of medicine and that's that's
Precision medicine but also what we call
Precision Health we really want to not
just figure out what drug treatment to
give this patient versus that treatment
but we really want to figure out who's
at risk of even getting some of these
diseases and gosh we could intervene now
and prevent them from ever getting in
trouble in the future
fantastic can't wait to hear more about
those developments and listen I want to
say on behalf of the listeners and
myself just thank you ever so much for
the discussion today I don't think I can
ever recall a conversation that's
included so much basic science and
clinical science and also so many
actionable recommendations both do's and
don'ts as it relates to something so
critical as Eye Health I also I was just
reflecting for a moment
about the fact that I think you and I
met 20 years ago when you were a
graduate student by the way folks
um Jeff is uh sort of the Kobe Bryant of
sorts although unfortunately still with
us in the sense that he went directly
from his MD and phds skipped his postdoc
didn't require one directly to being a
faculty member most people don't do that
they do a five-year postdoc in between
wait and then I believe he's going to
tell me all the places I'm wrong and I
should just come clean that
um Jeff is my chair of department at um
Stanford School of Medicine Department
of Ophthalmology so for me I I see this
as a particularly warming but also
um at once unpredictable but pure
pleasure of an experience to get to
learn so much from you because I don't
think we've had this long to sit down
and talk science in a very long time so
thank you for doing that for my own sake
thank you for teaching us so much about
how to take care of our Eye Health and
now you can tell me where my history is
wrong maybe my hippocampus is
degenerating no it's been a pleasure
over the years I have nothing but the
warmest memories of of you as a postdoc
and me as a graduate student getting to
be you know nerds in the laboratory uh
20 years ago 20 years ago at Stanford in
the lab of Ben Barris and uh and very
warm wonderful feelings about you know
learning science and how to do science
and making real advances even at that
time and then the fact that we've had
the chance to cross paths in San Diego
again at Stanford collaborate on
important projects having to do with you
know developing new ways of measuring
diseases developing new ways of treating
diseases the idea that we're going to
actually bring forward some of the
advances that our lab that you're a lab
that other people's Labs have been
making in neuroprotection in diseases
like glaucoma and macular degeneration
in regeneration of the optic nerve of
the retina we're real close on a lot of
those this is a major topic of really
The Cutting Edge research that we're
really trying to keep pushing forward
because we know it's so important to
patients you know I I often joke you
know my mother had a uh a sign outside
the bathroom and it said remember how
long a minute is depends on what side of
the door you're on and I I really
appreciate that like as fast as we're
trying to go with our research and
moving that into clinical research which
I think we're doing very effectively in
the department really working on Vision
restoration research in the department I
appreciate that as fast as we think
we're going it's not fast enough for so
many patients who are suffering from
these diseases so thanks very much for
having me on it's been a real pleasure
reconnecting over these many important
topics I really appreciate the chance to
talk with you well delighted to do it
and looking forward to doing it again
you're an amazing colleague friend
clinician and now public health educator
thank you
thank you for joining me for today's
discussion all about I Envision Health
with Dr Jeffrey Goldberg I hope you
enjoyed the discussion as much as I did
if you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review please also check out
the sponsors mentioned at the beginning
and throughout today's episode that's
the best way to support this podcast in
addition if you have questions for me or
comments about the podcast or you'd like
to suggest a guest that I feature on the
huberman Lab podcast please put those in
the comments section on YouTube I do
read all the comments during today's
discussion and on many previous episodes
of The huberman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like improving sleep for hormone
support and for improving Focus the
uberman Lab podcast is partnered with
momentous supplements if you'd like to
see the supplements discussed on the
huberman Lab podcast you can go to live
momentous spelled ous so
livemomentis.com huberman if you're not
already following me on social media it
is huberman lab on Instagram Twitter
Facebook and Linkedin and all those
places I discuss science and science
related tools some of which overlap with
the content of the huberman Lab podcast
but much of which is distinct from the
content on the huberman Lab podcast so
again it's huberman lab on all social
media platforms if you haven't already
signed up for the huberman Lab podcast
neural network newsletter it is a zero
cost monthly newsletter that includes
podcast summaries as well as protocols
comprised of short PDFs that include
everything from a toolkit for Sleep a
tool kit for neuroplasticity or learning
toolkits for enhancing exercise toolkits
for enhancing various aspects of mental
health physical health and performance
again all zero cost and all available to
you simply by going to hubermanlab.com
go to the menu scroll down to newsletter
and provide your email we do not share
your email with anybody and again it's
the neural network newsletter and is
completely zero cost thank you once
again for joining me for today's
discussion with Dr Jeffrey Goldberg and
last but certainly not least thank you
for your interest in science
[Music]